foreign
well I know but the light is [__] up I
don't know why it's different looking
like marshes I thought I fixed it
yeah
um
we're uh okay that's not right yeah
that's not bad sorry keep going that's
blue
yeah yeah yeah
what kind of [__] is that
there's a dam that's probably that's
okay
what happened to the the thing that
I don't know you said the power went out
you think that destroyed it well I don't
know because I turned it back I turned
it on and it was bright white and I was
like that's not how I left it
do you um and usually well no because no
no okay I see what it's doing no you're
gonna have to do that yeah see
because that's
there it is there it is
okay
that was the one we had before
that makes sense it looks a little bit a
little sparkly candy
um we got a storm out there man it's
[__] it's it's come down it was
coming down to pretty much all day
um I got trapped over at Starbucks I
drew I had to drive through a [__]
yeah storm in between Daytona and DeLand
and I couldn't see the road yeah if we
uh lose the stream and you guys know why
it was terrible but it's the [__]
lightning going on out there and
everything yeah but it's uh Friday and
we're gonna Usher you into the weekend
uh with a Drake and any kind of stories
or several drinks Maybe
[Laughter]
looks like people are starting to
because I don't have to get up in the
morning which is nice looks like people
are filtering in yeah they're coming in
two by two
just like Noah's Ark yeah
Tammy's in there what's up Ted
prospective collectives there
um he just got what done watching [__]
the devil
and [__] the devil too return if the
[__] return
all right Ben's in there I'm gonna have
to see that sax there
see what Zach's up to
how does Pookie like the storm she she
doesn't they don't bother her that much
she knows what storm is she doesn't like
Fourth of July
yeah she was uh she was real upset on
Fourth of July she just went right into
the bed and Tom tried to get her out and
she's like nope not having it yep hit
underneath the bed and was wherever I
was on on top of the bed she was
directly underneath me yeah hiding under
me
if one of them [__] bombs comes
through the window it's gonna get Daddy
and I will be safe yeah he'll he'll
absorb the black
she's really smart she's not dumb
trying to put me in between her and the
bomb yeah see like I said she's not dumb
at all she's not dumb at all I tried to
put her I tried to show her I let her
look outside the window and saw the
fireworks she's like nope nope nope
she's like that was even today before
scared yeah what do you do because I
told her I was like well I told Tom like
don't do that because that's just gonna
stress her out and she doesn't
understand well I thought she would see
that then it's far away right and but to
her I mean it probably looked like even
scarier yeah she didn't know what it was
yeah UFOs yeah when I came home from
work I saw Beijing skulking around up
here yeah she doesn't usually comes up
here
did we get along oh they were yeah okay
because I thought it was funny because I
saw like a little Shadow and I was like
hey it's Beijing she doesn't usually
come upstairs and then she like looked
down and pookie was like down on the
snare landing and they were like looking
at each other like from she was Beijing
was up here and pookie was down there
like looking at each other and I'm like
uh oh there's gonna be a kitty Rumble
but I guess not I guess not bees nests
here also known as murder hornet
yeah we're still we're still calling you
all by like your old screen
[Laughter]
I don't know how how I would remember
like weird screens that's why I always
just kind of like use my regular name
for stuff I know his real name
yeah I know his real name so you know
well I know all those handles you know
you know all the all the special secret
information
real name is Keith
we shouldn't told anybody he didn't tell
you he didn't say but they're gonna find
you now
[__]
yeah maybe that's why people use like I
don't know like I said I would never be
remember
bad enough I can't remember all the
[__] passwords for the 40 million
sites I have yeah much less weird names
too
but yeah so uh what's everybody doing
today nothing too exciting going on
at least not here just regular [__]
right
I mean
I've just been at work all day today it
was really boring yeah it was just
another boy it was a boring day today
it's another boring day worked on the
bike today
everything chipped out
I got stranded last week
you had to come get me battery died yeah
and it's a lithium ion batteries a
shurai Racing battery it only weighs
like two pounds
and um you can't jump those you need a
computer to recharge a little
computerized charger
but I'd had that battery for five or six
years
so I got my money's worth out of that
thing that thing was 200 something
dollars that battery but the bike was so
light
the only way I could have lost 10 pounds
was like five thousand dollars worth of
dab carbon fiber or something you know
well it's cheaper just to do two two
hundred dollars in [__] lithium ion
battery you get a lot of weight savings
and uh that thing lasted a long time
I'll get another one but I got a lead
battery in there now
doesn't really make a big difference
that much weight you know
not with what I'm doing I'm not racing
or anything
and having a lead battery that you can
charge on hand that's good to have
I'll probably get another shirai
eventually put it in there maybe get it
for Christmas or something but uh it's
not absolutely necessary I'm gonna I'm
gonna go back to lead for a while and
see if there was a difference in the way
that it rides
then um
I didn't know that I had to check
my stator output
voltage regulator it all checked out it
was just a bad battery or seemingly so
it should be should be good it's
charging a 12 point
four seven volts which as long as it's
over 12 volts it should be okay
yeah I hope so yeah it's a Harley
Sportster style engine so
taxes Jenny number one book you'd like
to see as a movie
um
probably drude by Dan Simmons I think
that would make a great [__] movie I
don't know if like people would go see
it but I would I would want to see it I
did a review of the book like not too
long ago I think but it was the one that
was Charles Dickens and Wilkie Collins
like trying to find this creepy dude
with no nose you know what I mean like
the scary dude though it's like at a
train wreck
but yeah it's really good it's like
historical fiction but it's also kind of
like horror you know what I mean yeah I
mean they made that they made that other
Dan Simmons thing into it like the
terror they made that into a series so
it's like I was like why don't they make
Druid into a series I would watch it
Camp guy said he made onion pakoras
pakoras are good oh yummy slightly
shredded it's an Indian dish you just
take uh vegetables of certain kinds and
kind of shred them and you uh batter
them
and fry them in like these little balls
it's almost like a vegetable hush puppy
the Indian vegetable Hush Puppy they're
pretty good man that sounds good yeah
I've made I only made those once a long
time ago
Tom made uh calzone calzone calzone yeah
yeah and I made the cheese yeah he made
made the ricotta yeah made it in the
instant pot I had it had a half a gallon
of spoiled milk yeah it went sour
okay so what can I do for this and
looked and says you can
make cream you can make cottage cheese
paneer or ricotta out of it so I made
ricotta it came out [__] great yeah
it's really good yeah you just cook it
with a little bit of lemon juice in it
then you gotta strain it and then you'll
have the
you have the cheese and the Whey it's
fluid I kept that too
and when I made the crust instead of
using water I used the Whey and it made
a big difference in the crust yeah real
good I still got some that way left and
there's protein in there so you might as
well just use it
um so I got that in the refrigerator in
a glass jar
and I'm gonna make some more
but I looked at the
I looked at the uh at the price
that was just that cheap
Dollar Store milk
it's only like three three dollars and
something cents a gallon
and a half a gallon so it's like a
hundred like a dollar seventy worth of
milk made about four or five dollars
worth of ricotta cheese yeah so yeah
making it yourself is a lot more
economical yeah I had totally forgotten
that you can make all that [__] in the
instant pot you can make paneer in there
you can make yogurt in there you can
make all kinds of them
it's got settings for it so yeah it was
like it didn't take long either it was
it was easy and see that was something
you would have just thrown away I would
have just thrown it away and I was like
man I [__] turn that [__] and [__]
ricotta see I was like I always like
that I was like when you can find ways
to like use [__] and the um
the milk doesn't have to be sour
it can be fresh milk
it's just that they said if the milk
goes sour don't throw it away right turn
it into cheese
or yogurt yeah might as well yeah
your word great
it really did I mean yeah it's [__]
delicious came out really good yeah
you'd also make mozzarella out of
spoiled milk yeah
things they needed ricotta so I went I
had I had mozzarella yeah
Oscar said I saw a field in England the
other day Jenny it was pretty good
albeit kind of pointless
[Laughter]
yeah it's one of those movies that I
kind of feel like I really liked it but
I kind of feel like you're either gonna
really really like it or you're really
really not gonna like
it's a weird [__] movie that's for
sure what's up Oscar how you doing
Paradise
and subjective perspective Collective
says I'm hearing people are let down by
the new Insidious yeah I mean some I one
of y'all asked I think
um that maybe we should cover all the
Insidious movies one of these days which
I think I've only seen the first two
because there's more than that right I
hope there are three or four of them at
this point or maybe five
I remember really liking the first one
and the second one being okay I don't
think Tom's ever seen them no I've never
seen him you might like them maybe
I don't know it's hard to tell
I'll give anything a chance yeah like I
said we did actually watch Megan
and I we really likes that so I'm really
really excited yeah Megan was awesome it
was great writing yeah great writing
yeah that was a fun movie I had a good
time yeah and it was kind of like an old
to me is like a classic horror kind of
sci-fi type movie it was kind of
traditional in a lot of ways I thought
it was great it's like something that
they would have made I don't know in the
80s or the 90s
but it uh the technology special effects
are really good the writing was really
good
and that's kind of how I picture AI
being
if if you had Ai and you programmed it
like that's probably how it would be
yeah it would probably get terribly
sideways yeah just like in that movie
yes it's about this woman that's uh
she's a works for a toy company does
robotics
and uh
she had this experimental toy but the
fact but the the company wasn't
interested in it because it it [__] up
and it would have been too expensive it
would have been for the consumer Market
probably too well
her sister and and her husband got
killed in a car wreck or was it the
brother anyway she inherited her niece
she had to take care of her
she's like a nine-year-old girl
so she brings that robot out that she
built
and completed it and made it as a
companion for it had Ai and everything
and um it was so good she showed it to
the company
and the company wanted to make them
but in the meantime it was living with a
girl and it
it bent over backwards to protect that
girl it was killing dogs and killing
people and
coming up with solutions to things
and the robot was a robot of like a 10
year old girl
you put it you know it was just like
this pretty little kind of Alice in
Wonderland looking [__] robot
looks like a living doll
and it was funny because it looked uh
in general it looked uh kind of innocent
kind of harmless harmless and just kind
of cute
but there was something real kind of
Sinister about it especially as it
started to go sideways
and then eventually
showed you what a robot could actually
do and she could [__] run faster than
a dog on all fours and track people down
and do all kinds of cool [__] she could
fight
yeah I love that scene where she tore
that kid's ear off that's pretty awesome
[Laughter]
but yeah start dancing with blades
dancing and doing like acrobatics and
there's run up walls and jump off things
and cut people's heads off
but somebody slasher flick I mean you
can see and it's crazy because it was
only PG-13 but you but that just goes to
show that you can actually make a horror
movie that's PG-13 that's still good
yeah like without you see what I thought
that I thought that the thing was going
to be basically Chucky
that's what I was expecting this would
be like a Chucky movie that was a lot
better than that
yeah I really liked it and like I said I
can see why it got um
why it got like raptures reviews all
over the place it had really good
writing it was well thought out
and I think I'm pretty sure also that
Renfield is on peacock now and I really
want to see that that looks [__]
amazing so I don't know maybe we'll
watch that this weekend that's the thing
we like we wouldn't have normally like
watched this many movies so now I'm
gonna have to decide like which one
we're gonna talk about like on Sunday we
could either do Megan or last night we
watched Dreamscape from 1984.
so we might do that
or if we watch Renfield this weekend we
might do that one
Oscar's in here says what's up Tom Misty
left me
do you make a net public huh
well she left you so you go back there
and go get her probably well
you gotta commit [__]
you're not committing
is that what the issue is yeah I don't
really I was gonna say that because I'm
just gonna say that because that's
that's usually what it is
yeah I mean I guess not always but yeah
I guess so yeah
Zach says I rewatched the changeling
recently and that would probably be
considered PG-13 these days yeah it
probably would because nothing real gory
or anything happens in that movie like
what is is the changeling rated PG
changing which one was the change the
one with George C Scott oh the ghost
story the really good one yeah probably
from 81 probably PG I don't think
there's any uh
I don't think there's any Gore in it
yeah it's not gory it's like a ghost I
don't even think I don't even think
there's any cussing in that
yeah now I'm trying to think Georgie
George George C Scott Price says damn in
it yeah so it's probably fabulous
I mean it's got like upsetting themes I
think they should like they show like a
kid being drowned and [__] like that but
it's like you know it's not super bloody
or anything
but yeah I kind of feel like a lot of
movies back then probably
well PG-13 didn't come around until
the 80s right the mid 80s yeah I think
so well I was just reading about because
I was reading about Dreamscape earlier
and I think that was only that might
have been only the second movie to get a
PG-13 rating I think the first one was
Red Dawn actually
but so that so that was 84. yeah did we
did we do a review of Red Dawn I
remember we watched it like a couple
years ago I think we did
Red Dawn I remember watching it but I
don't remember us reviewing it
that's my uh least favorite movie about
my favorite uh record
yeah what's his name
my [__] braids not working what's
that dude's name again I know that
feeling
guy Dakota here's John millius John
millius yeah yeah yeah speaking of which
we still haven't watched the rest of
room yeah when did I buy you that I
bought you that series like for
Christmas like two years ago yeah we
never finished the second season I think
we started the second season but we
don't yeah we didn't give her that's the
thing it's like we just get because I
like I'll watch movies and stuff like
that and I like and I try to watch
series too but it's like sometimes I'll
watch like you know a few episodes I'm
like oh man that was really good but
then for whatever reason I end up
watching other things and like I just
never get back to it you know
uh subjective perspective says
Dreamscape is great I remember watching
it on VHS as a double feature with
Nightmare on Elm Street yeah because I
kind of feel like they even they both
came out in 1984 which is crazy and
they're not they're not similar similar
movies because I wouldn't necessarily
call Dreamscape a horror movie but they
have very similar themes as in like um
you know being able to manipulate the
real world like three dreams you know
what I mean
which is weird that they both came out
like the same time because there's no
way that one could have ripped off the
other one because I think they were in
production at the same time
yeah Oscar said yeah haha commitment
issues on my part yeah I figured
you'll be back you'll be back
you'll be back yeah how are you gonna
how are you gonna resist that red head
man come on
[Laughter]
you guys both got kids and everything
come on you'll be back
yeah we'll see how that goes what are
you gonna do dude
well you know maybe maybe he didn't get
along you know we thought she was cool
yeah from what we could see yeah
ooh Thunder
Ben says not that Angelina Jolie one
with the ax murders of children the wine
Bill Chicken Coop murders no that one
was just called changeling but that's
also a good movie but it's like
completely different yeah that was like
based on a true story and it's not
Supernatural we were talking about the
one from 1981 with George C Scott that's
like it's like a creepy ghost story Zach
says um I really didn't find changeling
very scary but I was super into the
mystery part of it I wish more
paranormal stories had like detective
elements yeah that's I really do like I
tend to like ghost stories that are also
murder mysteries you know what I mean
that's I think that's why I really like
like Stirrup Echoes and um the ring
and [__] like that because it has like a
murder mystery detective kind of element
to it and I'm really really into that
there's some old sleepers from around
that time that I liked too I was really
into the Legacy and I don't think a lot
of people like that one but I liked it I
liked it too yeah and it was just about
some check that
gets called to England to uh
I guess she was going to observe
the passing of some real rich guy and he
was going to hand out his inheritance
yeah I don't remember why she got it
invited I don't think she knew why she
got invited no she didn't not at first
yeah but she got there was all these
Freakazoid people that were super rich
in this big old mansion
some of them were rock stars and some of
Roger Daltrey yeah you know and
one by one they all start dying it turns
out they're all satanic witches
they have [__] real powers
and uh before the the old guy's gonna
die he's like a head Warlock
it's pretty cool
and um he's killing them off for
different reasons
using his powers
and then uh he plans to hand his [__]
Legacy over to the Survivor to give his
powers away before he dies it's pretty
good flick I liked yeah I feel like it's
a little bit underrated yeah
it was kind of like the changeling it
was it was kind of a mystery yeah not as
creepy not as creepy right
um but it did have Supernatural elements
and it had Catherine Ross in it who was
also in The Stepford Wives and it had
Sam Elliott a very young Sam Elliott
that's right
which is crazy when that just reminded
me because we were watching Dreamscape
last night I hadn't seen Dreamscape in
like a million years and so I had
forgotten I remember Dennis Quaid being
in it obviously because he's like the
star but I totally forgotten Max von
said I was in that and like when we were
watching it Tom was like was Max Fons I
know always old yeah and I was young and
I was like well I mean he was in like a
bunch of ingmar Bergman movies like back
in the 60s and stuff like that like hour
the wolf and whatnot and I was like he
didn't look old old back then but he
also didn't look all that young he was
just one of those dudes that always
looked like a cool old man you know yeah
sorta
one of the things I liked about the
Legacy though was the special effects
they were practical effects and the way
they showed
magical powers and sorcery was just to
edit like remember they tried to leave
like [__] it these people are nuts let's
get the [__] out of here yeah and they
get in the car and they leave and they
drove there
but they couldn't drive out yeah every
path that they took through the roads
LED back
yeah I love that kind of [__] and they
were like how's this possible there's no
Road out of here we drove here you know
and that that was the the whole movie's
like that
um
one dude drowns
in the pool because it was a woman
drowned in the pool because she couldn't
break the surface tension on the water
she couldn't get out of the water that
was weird it was like it was solid yeah
so there's all kind of Witchcraft
witchcraft Shenanigans happening
dude's choking on bones that it couldn't
have been a bone he was eating pork but
it was a [__] turkey bone or a
chicken bone in it yeah then he was
eating pork yeah like why does this pig
have chicken bones yeah
Ben says PG 24 was for TV or Cinema I'm
not really sure what PG 24 is that must
be some British [__] well I don't know
Ben's Australian anymore you're
Australian right we don't have we have
G
which is General audiences that's
anybody can see that's usually kids
movies then you have PG which is just uh
what's that stands for Parental Guidance
right then there's PG-13 which is like a
PG but like slightly maybe more stuff so
you have to be like over 13 before you
see it and then there's just R oh and
also there's nc17 but not a lot of
movies get rated nc17 anymore I think
because they there was kind of a stigma
about it where a lot of theaters
wouldn't show them and a lot of
retailers wouldn't sell them like when
they came out on DVD or Blu-Ray so a lot
of times like for example it's different
nowadays but for example infinity pool
which we just talked about uh the
original cut the director's Cut Is was
actually rated nc17 but um they cut a
few things out like to get an R but then
they can release like another unrated
version which is what they've done
because the version we watched which was
on Hulu was the R-rated version but if
you go to YouTube and rent it it's the
nc7 team one but I think all they took
out was just a couple more
um like explicit sexual shots
pretty much I think that was all they
took out at least from what I could
determine
uh grandpa said took my kids to see the
new Indiana Jones uh you have big waste
of time and money yeah I now I what I
heard I hadn't really watched that many
um things of it I just heard people
talking about it some people said well
it was okay but it was like better than
Crystal Skull but that's not good enough
but well like I said Crystal Skull
wasn't great so yeah I I'm not
interested I don't really care
uh but what is interesting what is
interesting is just the trouble that
Disney Corporation is in they that movie
was [__] is super super expensive and
they've just had nothing but a long
string of flops and that that movie too
I think they they reshot that thing over
and over again
and uh they added new endings on it for
that movie to make any money I think
even to break even it was it was so
incredible had to make a billion dollars
so that was a loser to begin with see
like I said I was just like there's
really too much fun you're really
shooting yourself in the dick like
making these big
well like Temple kind of movies like
other than Marvel that'll probably get
it they they usually like lots of money
but not anymore well the thing about it
is it's probably better now to go the
route of like do like lesser they should
be cheap like less expensive yes much
easier to make your money back the
market isn't there anymore uh I've been
watching programs all past past two or
three days
just watch up Midnight's Edge they have
insiders and creative people just trying
to analyze what the [__] going on in
the market just what what it is is that
the market isn't there anymore
they don't really make these movies for
people that go to movies uh they try to
bring them to younger audiences and
younger audiences don't give a [__]
about them then they piss off the older
audiences that would go to see it it's
these are movies made by committees and
whenever that happens you're not going
to have any art
The Originals of all these movies that
they're that they are copying like the
first Indiana Jones was a work of
[__] art
okay that's why that movie was so good
it wasn't some formula
uh so that you you can't do that again
if you're gonna do it through a
formulaic
that and here and this is how
short-sighted they are
they're scared to death of unknowns so
they can't make any original material
they would rather make some something in
some kind of a box some kind of sequel
some kind of add-on to another movie
because they can supposedly in the past
they were able to predict how much money
it would make so they knew how much to
spend but corruption in there and greed
got so bad that they're handing out all
this [__] money shareholders money to
all their friends to make this movie and
they don't really care whether or not it
makes its money back or any profit
they'd just rather just run Disney into
the ground the shareholders will [__]
take it's not their money
all that shit's coming to an end there's
in
their insiders leaking [__] inside
Disney headquarters they say the place
is Panda [__] ammonium
[__] ton of people have been fired
big names are good their their heads are
going to roll because they're not even
making much money at the parks right now
like a like an all-time low the past 10
years
and if you look it
Disney Orlando here Disney World
that Park sucks compared to [__]
um
Universal Universal just blows it out of
the [__] water
they're just not the King of the Hill
anymore man they're just a tired old
[__] what's a good uh bureaucracy
really and they just can't they just
can't survive I I believe they're gonna
be I believe they're going to sell huge
pieces of themselves off they're
probably going to sell Star Wars
probably gonna sell Marvel stuff off
they they shouldn't they can't make
movies
they've proven it they can't make them
they nothing but bombs like two or three
years in a row
the talent's not there
you can't make movies by committees
not anymore
well I mean the thing about it is that
there's really no I mean since the
Advent of streaming and since the you
know making a movie has become much
cheaper
um you know there's a lot more
competition now there's a lot more
streaming services there's a lot more
independent people making movies and
[__] like that so people are just going
to gravitate you don't have it's you
know it's not like it was in the 70s and
80s when everybody would go see like the
big summer movie or whatever like
everybody's gonna go see it like now
it's like you know there's you could
live your entire life without seeing any
kind of like mainstream stuff you just
like you could you could just have the
rest of your life and just 24 7 have
[__] that you like on whether it's TV
series or movies or something like that
and you never run out of stuff because
there's just so much and social media
has given modern viewers the ability
to keep track of the past and to talk to
one another it used to be you could put
out a shitty movie and then the next
year or the next move you put out be
okay and then next would be shitty and
the next would be real good
and it wouldn't really tarnish your
reputation too much
it's not the key that's not the
situation now everybody knows who Disney
is everybody knows that their movies
[__] suck they don't go they don't go
see them
and started with
Disney sucking
and then the Marvel movie started to
suck
and then Willow sucks so bad that they
pulled it off the [__] Market just
after a couple months they pulled it off
Disney plus and tried to use it as a tax
write-off they [__] they just blow up
Indiana Jones [__] sucks you know
evidently it just nobody went to see it
and then Mel Gibson's [__] movie
about child documentary about child
trafficking is kicking its [__] ass
and that movie was made for nothing
and it's because they want those movies
to be expensive and then they want them
to make a lot of money or they don't
really care but they're hoping that
they'll make a lot of money but they
want them to be real expensive because
that's given paychecks to all their
friends that's all that is
they want the movie to cost [__] a
half a billion dollars
I don't care if it [__] they don't
care if it bombs because they got the
check they bought the Mansion they got
the house they got the pool they don't
give a [__]
the corporations she can't put up with
that [__] they gotta [__] fire these
people
and you got to give them limits to what
they could do you know what I mean you
can't
[__] let Disney decide how much money
it's going to spend the shareholders got
to figure that [__] out
Tammy says I heard they're finally
working on the second season of taboo
the Tom Hardy series that he worked on
with his dad I didn't even know there
was a first season well now I have to
kind of watch that some of the most
impressive [__] over the past couple
years that me and Jen have seen were
little independent films
well I mean in my I think that's for me
that's always been the case I mean I
have I do like like some big mainstream
movies like from the 70s and 80s and
maybe the 90s but generally my favorite
movies are usually more independent
movies or smaller movies and like I said
because I'm a big horror person and a
lot of those you know you don't usually
get any big tent pole horror movies
that's just not usually there's not
enough horror fans out there to support
a billion dollar movie you know what I
mean there are movies out there that
were just made for nothing they were
just real gems like that little French
independent film turbo kid which is a
post-apocalyptic [__] superhero movie
I think that's on 2B now I'm gonna see
that again I want to own that movie
that's a that was a good movie not made
for anything but it was just good
writing and it was entertaining to watch
Michael Ironside was in it and he was
being himself in it it was it gave the
audience what they wanted
that Megan
uh movie was that was that was blumhouse
I think yeah and that's and blumhouse I
mean they kind of kick ass because
they're I mean not all their movies have
been great some of them are just kind of
average but they don't spend a lot of
money they only spend a couple million
dollars maybe
um and they usually get a big return on
it I have been at least satisfied at
least satisfied with every Blum House
movie I've seen I didn't feel like I got
ripped off we saw him in the theater
it's like okay it was decent yeah like I
said never of them were like oh [__]
that you know I never had a negative
reaction yeah it's always at least okay
yeah they were at least usually
entertaining yeah like you know yeah I
fully endorsed Bloom house from
everything I've seen we saw a lot of
their [__]
um even the okay here's another thing
Indiana Jones and [__] Disney they're
gonna [__]
their face is going to get rubbed in it
soon when that [__] mission
impossible comes out because Tom Cruise
can [__] deliver right now all right
and that that last top gun Maverick that
made a [__] ton of move money all right
everybody who saw top gun Maverick is
going to see Mission Impossible I love
Mission Impossible I think it's a great
it's right up there with [__] Daniel
Craig James Bond
I like him as Ethan Hunt he's good and
each one of those movies is pretty much
its own movie one of them was a John
John wooflick with real dated but that
was popular at that time
Tom Cruise is going to tear it out of
the [__] frame here in a couple weeks
when is that do you remember that movie
it's got to be soon because I've already
seen
um like some of my reviewers have
already seen it and usually they get to
see it maybe like a few days earlier a
week early so it's either coming out
this weekend or next weekend and here's
the weird thing
Tom Cruise delivers but none of that
shit's real
artistic or revolutionary it's it's
standard [__] yeah that top gun Maverick
movie was just standard [__]
yeah it wasn't anything to like write
home about her no it was just a well
executed good movie it was what it was
it was basically a retelling of Star
Wars A New Hope they're destroying the
Death Star
yeah I mean and basically what they're
doing that's exactly what they were
doing yeah
even play
they were homage in that [__] it didn't
go in now
if I knew exactly what they were talking
about I think I think I even said that
in the dude in the Star Wars dude's
voice yeah like when they missed it I
was like nope it didn't go in it
just impacted
yeah and uh [__] they knew that we
knew what that was yeah and then uh
and even though Cruz has done some
[__] pretty
um I think artistic flicks
that's not what he's doing lately he's
just giving standard [__] and people are
going to see it
so
the people that will the older audience
that's another thing these are older
people see in his movies
40s and 40 plus yeah a lot of them
well there's a lot of them out there
which which is ridiculous because
these uh Disney would say oh no that
those that that crowd is too old
they'll never come see the movie we need
a young audiences young audiences don't
have any [__] money
you know the old audience does same
thing with all these Collectibles like
the Star Wars collectible [__] kids
don't want that [__] old men want that
you know the Star Wars action figures
probably average age of a [__] buyer
is probably [__] mid 40s mid 50s
buying that [__]
let's see
come on
I've seen I see him in their talk it's
Becca okay okay are we back back should
be back we had a lightning strike yeah
sorry lightning struck
we told you before we started it's like
it's storming outside
so that's the weird thing about these uh
movies is that the
the Committees that are making them
don't understand the market anymore
uh they're trying to recreate night the
1970s in the 1980s
and uh theater isn't what it was
younger people watch things on [__]
on devices they don't go to theaters too
much they get they don't it's not in
their culture
Ben says black phone was blumhouse I
actually ended up liking black phone
much more than I thought I would uh the
only complaint that I had about it
because I did a video about it not too
long ago the only complaint I had was I
didn't because I saw the trailer like a
million times but the trailer kind of
gave most of the movie away which was
kind of a bummer but I really really
liked the tone of it I really liked like
the Retro look of it I just I don't know
I just like the way it was shot and it
was like a much darker than I thought
like it went way into like the whole
child abuse angle and all that kind of
stuff and it didn't like shy away from
showing that kind of [__]
and so I ended up liking that like a
great deal more than I thought I would
it was much better than I was expecting
so there was that and then John Smith
said Megan was a surprise hit yeah it it
really was which like I said just goes
[__] I don't know how much that cost to
make yeah but um probably not that much
I'd imagine but it just goes to show
that it's like you have like a good
premise like that doesn't have to be a
super original premise like you said
it's you know that's been done before
but it was just really well executed you
know
I'm trying this device is trying to
connect to the Wi-Fi it's not I can't
believe we have a connection here yeah
we just lost it for a few seconds yeah
the um like it was the lightning strike
yeah
because he can you can you hear it
yeah Hugo said I try not to watch
trailers anymore yeah I don't either
it's just that a lot of times when we
were going to the movies all the time I
would you know I would see all the
trailers so I saw the black phone
trailer like a lot of times like a
couple years back because they would
show it every time we were there but I
don't like I don't seek out trailers now
at all like if I hear about a movie and
there's like a buzz about it and I like
the you know it's this horror movies
coming out I like that director I like
the actor it's in it or something like
that I'll just see it I don't I don't
even like to read the synopsis
you know I've even gotten to that point
where I'm just like you know what I'm
just gonna watch it without having any
like preconceived
Notions about it sometimes that bites me
in the ass but not usually I kind of
like going into movies not really
knowing what they're about
because when when we um when we watched
infinity pool literally the only thing I
knew about it was it was Brandon
Cronenberg and like I knew that you know
Mia goth and Alexander Skarsgard were in
it but it was like I didn't I didn't
know it was about and I don't want to
know I hadn't seen a trailer or nothing
I said I'm just gonna watch it and I'm
just gonna let it kind of like unfold
you know
foreign
yeah Kalyn said what's also terrifying
to Studio execs in Hollywood is how
decentralized entertainment has become
and that we really don't need Hollywood
generally no you don't need them well
that's kind of what I was saying is that
you know there's so many streaming
services and there's so many independent
movies and there's just so much content
that you really don't need I mean you
know a lot of people still do go see
those big Temple movies but it's like
you don't need to I mean there's tons
and tons of other stuff to watch like I
said I'll never live long enough to see
everything I want to see
so they're kind of they're kind of
getting what they deserve though I mean
they they had a monopoly on the big
screen in the United States for [__]
almost 100 years at least 100 years
um they started in the early 1900s
and they just ran that [__] into the
ground
and here's the thing man but Hollywood
wasn't always good it had periods where
it was pretty good different eras
people forget a lot of times that
[__] most of the [__] Silver
Screen 20s and 30s most of it was
schlock according to Witnesses well yeah
they were just kind of like cheap and
that's that's what always kind of like
makes me laugh about people nowadays is
like oh everything just remakes and
sequels I'm like it was back then too
what does it like they go back to like
oh the golden days of Hollywood like the
20s and 30s I'm like that's all it was
in the 30s pretty much the 30s and 40s
was all sequels and knockoffs and [__]
like yeah it was crap evidently and a
lot of it doesn't exist anymore but
Witnesses said it was crap especially
foreign Witnesses they could speak
English like man this [__] movies are
shitty
um
70s in general was [__] horrible
uh some of the movies are real good they
did have some good movies like bulletin
and you know they're just some 70s
Classics can really stand out Star Wars
was a 70s classic but that wasn't really
Hollywood Star Wars was in flick
and uh some of the best films of the 70s
were
um small
were were
um kind of like independent directors
you know Steven Spielberg George Lucas
they were coming out of the scene they
were replacing the old Krusty guys they
were doing it in in in a better way new
way you know Jaws Close Encounters
[__] Star Wars
Indiana Jones
and some of that [__] was retro like
Indiana Jones was a retro take on
[__] cereals you know
so um
kind of retro futuristic kind of [__] so
they kind of picked up the vibe better
than a lot of the guys at the same
because most 70s movies were [__]
kind of hard-boiled dry cop movies
because they replaced the westerns
and westerns got really bad
um it wasn't until spaghetti western
Sergio Leoni and
Clint Eastwood came in he changed he
came up with some good westerns and
those were mostly independent
Eastwood flicks
I don't think there were any I don't
think Hollywood Studios were behind that
usually
I don't think they did High Plains
Drifter did it I don't know I think that
was an independent film
I mean the thing about it was that you
know it's honestly the 70s if if
somebody made me pick the 70s are
probably my favorite decade at least for
horror films like most of my favorite
horror films came out in the 70s or the
early 80s
you know what I mean yeah but I thought
well I think the stream movies weren't
that good though no but I think that
that's the case in a lot of eras yeah
now in the 80s like a lot of the big
mainstream movies were actually good
um not all of them a lot of them like if
you watch them now you're like wow
that's kind of terrible but
I don't know it's it's kind of like a
mixed bag
because I'm always kind of like I'm not
like a super nostalgic person like I
said I do like movies from the 70s and
80s like that I grew up with and
everything but I am perfectly willing to
watch a movie that I loved back then and
if I think it sucks now then I'll say it
sucks now you know what I mean a lot of
those movies like the one we watched
last night that Dreamscape movie yeah
that was pretty good
um and it was mostly just because of the
writing
take that movie
and just reshoot it and keep all the
writing the same and that'd do pretty
well
it probably would yeah just with a
little bit more modern
special effects uh but that movie would
do pretty well because they got the
storytelling right well it's a good
premise yeah it's a good premise and
it's kind of believable it was kind of
like a kind of like a Michael Crichton
flick for me you know it did kind of
have that little bit of a tone yeah it
had that tone to me but it also had like
a paranormal thing right almost sound
like fire starter yeah
what was that other Stephen King flick
where they're dealing with [__]
paranormal you're dead though Dead Zone
and apparently it was like that
um
and like I said it was a good flick it
almost had like a well it was weird
because it almost had like the same kind
of thing as Nightmare and Elm Street
even though it's not a horror movie
because it's kind of like yeah we're
going to people's dreams and like
[__] them up and [__] like that but
then it was almost like a 70s political
thriller yeah like it had that aspect to
remember what it was reminding me of so
it reminded me a little bit of Altered
States too yeah it definitely gave me
like an Altered States kind of vibe
that's and I remember like when I saw it
back in the 80s that it that's what it
mostly reminded me of even though
Altered States is a lot more serious and
a lot weirder yeah you know what I mean
I kind of feel like Dreamscape is sort
of like the mainstream political
thriller version of Altered States if
that makes any sense I think I had seen
Dreamscapes in the theater
um
I didn't I forgot all about it but as I
was watching the movie I was remembering
the scenes yeah like when the little guy
was
dreaming that he was catching his wife
cheating on him yeah and when he gets up
there and he he asks Dennis Quaid is in
his dream with her are you scared
because no he goes no he goes you sure
yeah come on let's go they get up there
and the wife's [__] he could hear the
wife [__] getting they were just
somebody was just knocking her down like
crazy and he gets up there and he goes
oh my God my my own brother and in front
of the kids the children are sitting
there in the chair as well that made me
laugh out loud I had forgotten about
that and then look at all these dudes
car falling start filming falling out
from underneath the bed who you too and
all my friends he's dreaming that his
wife was cheating on him with all these
different dudes even his Japanese client
was was [__] his wife I remembered
that [__] remember that [__] but I was
like in my teen my early teen years I
was like laughing what a weird scene
that was though yeah in front of the
kids and they're in chairs sitting next
to the bed watching it watching Mom
humping all the dudes yeah yeah I'm just
like all right yeah
that was his nightmare
it's a little bit weird dad
he had all he had uh performance anxiety
problems yeah he had sexual anxiety if
you thought he was inadequate I thought
it was an inadequacy issues yeah so he
thought like all these other dudes well
the thing was is he was a little he was
a little dumpy guy yeah in his 50s and
his wife was [__] the hottie in her
[__] 20s it looked like her maybe
early 30s yeah so yeah you would think
that
yeah probably that she married him for
his money was [__] all these other
dudes
which they never established if that was
the case but he just thought that he
just thought that right yeah that's what
he was dreaming about because he was
yeah
yeah but I think a guy would think that
though yeah probably she was too high
for him
so the sun was up Juan says hello Tom
and Jen how are you what's up Hi how are
you doing uh we're doing pretty good uh
Caitlyn Higgins said it's people like
you guys Tom and Jen that are the new
entertainment alternative media is
rising fast we kind of YouTube people
and uh people on Rumble and what's the
other one uh [__] twitch
we replaced television not movies but
television where's the uh
tell it and radio to a certain extent
sent too kind of like radio shows
uh subjective perspective said have you
all seen antlers I love that we did we
saw in the theater I didn't love it um I
thought I liked the concept of it
but I don't know there was something I
mean I liked it overall but there was
something about it that just didn't
really
I don't know that didn't really hit me
you know what I mean so
I don't know I don't know what it was I
don't know what it was but
I don't know
I don't know I didn't love it
um what do we say uh Zach says the
director of uh whatever that word is and
the crow oh Alex Pro is yeah has a
patreon now and is a big supporter of
decentralized filmmaking too only five
dollars a month cool dude hey that's
pretty cool yeah I mean
I really like like I said I always like
back in this back in the 80s and [__]
like that my big dream was always to
like you know write horror novels and
stuff like that and back then
if you wrote a horror novel you either
had to pay thousands of thousands of
dollars to print a bunch yourself and
then try to sell them but no bookstore
would carry it or anything like that or
you had to approach an agent and then
the agent would have to approach a
publisher and they would have to publish
it and do the [__] for you but it's like
now you don't have to do that anymore
like you know people still do go that
route obviously but um you know people
that actually make a huge living at it
but you don't have to do that anymore
it's very very easy to like publish your
own [__] which I actually always really
liked to do because I don't
the less people that are involved in my
[__] like the better off I don't really
like really I'm not like a control freak
or anything like that but I don't like
especially if it's something that
I made like a book that I wrote or a
game that I thought up or something like
that I want it to be exactly the way I
pictured it I don't want other people
like coming in and [__] it up you
know what I mean like I don't I like I
want to design my own book covers I want
to do I want the layout to look exactly
the way I want it to look and stuff like
that and nowadays it's like easy to do
that whereas before you know you'd write
a novel and then it would go to a
publishing company and then they'd
assign an artist to it and then you know
they'd have another person and do like
the layout and everything like that so
it's just kind of like
you wouldn't have it exactly the way you
wanted it largely
and I don't know I don't like that I
just like everything looking the way I
want it to look so I'm glad that it's
easy to do that now
yeah when Jenny and I first started this
show years ago how long has it been now
oh [__] we started in 2016. yeah so
that's what five years six years almost
eight huh no wait what's 20 what's two
what's 20 23 minus 2016 that's four and
seven seven years yeah
I can't believe that it's been that long
yeah we've been doing this [__] for
seven years yeah
um that's ridiculous isn't it
it was box moving around yeah well she's
let him be a Vulcan okay she's like no
Juan says that drink looks good what is
it
it is vodka and Minute Maid fruit punch
Berry Punch no fruit punch fruit punch
okay I haven't opened the berry yet
um when the first the initial concept of
the show wasn't really to replace movies
or TV or anything like that it was
really to replace we were thinking more
along the lines of radio type show where
we were replacing
kind of like or not really replacing but
doing kind of the same thing Art Bell
was doing mixed with like [__]
[__] Howard Stern Show or something
you know and we were just gonna be kind
of like and it was gonna be interactive
and we were going to be basically online
friends
you know and just talk to people you
know that was it
and I think we pretty much called it
because that's
basically what it's basically what
YouTube shows are yeah you know they
seven years ago
you kind of had a
you kind of had habits from the old
world you're trying to do it in a
formalized setting we for a while we did
it as a dam remember like a slideshow
yeah
because we thought that'd be easier than
having a video component and eventually
the the the [__] show just got
stripped down to just live streaming
because it's efficient and fast response
to the market
and it's better if you see who's talking
to you you know because half the damn
product
is the personality of the people
delivering it I mean I gotta I you know
I'm not the only you know it's not like
I'm blind in this [__] show I got
[__] uh [__] YouTube shows that I
listen to religiously
you know [__] and I feel like I know
those people so I know what you're going
through I feel the same way
you know and it's better than television
I go back and watch recordings of
television programs that [__] was stale
as [__] and you couldn't interact with
it you're not sure who these people were
half the time you know they're kind of
playing a role
well I think we are actually like this
and [__] yeah the audience right now
grabbed his hammer we went to [__]
high school together he'd tell you no
this I was always like this and Jen is
actually like this
if you meet us in person this is just
we're just it's exactly the same I mean
I obviously like talk more than I do in
real life because like in real life I'm
usually like kind of quiet but yeah it's
everything's situational but it is
situational but yeah we're not any
different
like if you like if you came to our
house and like summer were like spying
on us or something like that like we
would be sitting around watching movies
to talk in the same kind of [__] that we
talk like yeah while we're on the show
and I said well I think that that was
the appeal
for things like this you know what I
mean where because I mean I like a lot
of [__] like that too like I you know
I'll watch [__] uh some channels like
you know I bring up Jade the Libra I
like her a lot she started out doing
like Halloween stuff but she does other
shows she did like a whole thing like
when she was pregnant and she was like
having the baby and she's like having
baby shower [__] and it's like I'll
watch her this is crazy I will watch her
clean her [__] bathroom she will make
a video like a cleaning bat like a
cleaning video and she'll just like go
through and like clean her bathroom and
like kind of talk during it and stuff
like that I'll even watch that yeah
which is [__] it's crazy you wouldn't
think that like you know 20 30 years ago
people were like hey I'm gonna watch
some person I don't know like clean
their bathroom or like organize their
closet or something like that but people
absolutely will because if they get to
know that person like through their
other videos and stuff like that then
it's just like hanging out with that
person yeah and I think people like that
yeah I'll listen to Ian from forgot and
weapons and he's just works for a dab
auction house for [__] rare and
exotic firearms and he'll just sit there
and just tell you everything the history
is some [__] weird
experimental
gun going back to the [__] 1500s
he'll [__] pull out some [__] from
the 1500s and show it to you or or
secret weapons from World War II small
arms and [__] he just knows everything
about him
uh and then they'll go out and shoot I'm
big into that I like Tim like Tim Poole
like uh uh I like to I like the
quartering uh I like
um
Midnight's Edge when it comes to uh
entertainment news I like Midnight's
Edge the best
um
well listen to Brandon 10 old he's
[__] funny as [__] I love Brandon
Town [__] case Cinema he just put up a
new one another he doesn't put up as
many anymore he only puts up one like
every few months or something whenever
he fails like it but he's always like
super funny anything with Michael malice
I'll listen to him
um
and then I'll listen to uh manosphere of
[__] and critique that or laugh you know
laugh along with him it's certain [__]
you know where
[__]
manosphere [__] [__] uh I like it
because
it reminds me of what it's like to be in
your 20s because most of those dudes are
in their 20s they don't know [__] about
it and they're seeing [__] from the
point of view of a guy in their 20s I
didn't know [__] about [__] yeah you're
right nobody does and I they're right
about a lot of the [__] they're talking
about but what they're talking about is
situational it kind of changes when you
get older and you start seeing things
more from other people's point of view
yeah he starts to crawl out of your own
ass yeah
yeah you know these girls aren't giving
you any play because you look like [__]
you know just [__] like that you know
what I mean stop [__] being so
obstistic you call an absolutistic but
you're you're a solipsistic too you know
it's a I think all that shit's funny you
know although some dudes come in there
some guys are real good they're coming
there and straighten those guys out
you know what I mean like these dudes
are [__] nuts they think once a woman
hits 30 she's undesirable like what the
[__] you talking about they don't get
good until about 30.
like I said because people in their 20s
are [__] dumb I didn't even really
get my [__] together until yeah
well they've lost their beauty like who
the [__] are you hanging
man
I kind of just feel sorry well actually
that's not true
if they're that [__] some of the
hottest women me and Jen know are in
their 30s and 40s they're [__]
smoking hot if I show you [__]
pictures of them you're like she's 40.
yeah they got them in their 50s that are
hot as [__]
but you know a lot of these guys are in
their 20s and they're looking to get
married and have kids so yeah that's too
old for you you don't you you know if
you're 23 you don't want to get married
and have kids with a 50 year old woman
no matter how hot she is
but if you're a 55 year old man and you
see a 50 year old woman she's [__]
smoking hot you're jacked
you know what I mean that's got your
name all over it she's single so but
they don't they haven't [__] adopted
that Viewpoint yet that that reality is
is a lot is situational
maybe they'll get older in there
so you understand this [__] yeah
like I feel like young dudes are very
narrow-minded yeah but then here's the
[__] funny thing they they they're
jerking it [__] constantly to [__]
porn and they're not [__] honing
their game to go out there and meet
women in the wild all right and [__]
have a relationship they're jerking it
to all the [__] porn constantly and
these girls that they're jerking it to
are in their 40s and 50s they don't
realize that I guess maybe not yeah
because it does seem like that seems to
be and [__] like every every porn
platform we like look at like even
streamate and stuff like that most of
the top performers are 40s older yeah
yeah or older women yeah
like they still they look fantastic I'm
not saying that but it's like a cougar
thing or MILFs yeah yeah that's like
that it seems like the top thing yep so
and like pretty and I think that's true
of like pretty much every porn platform
that's one of the top categories a lot
of guys in their 20s you know they think
of a 50 year old woman they think of
some old hag and like [__] no man
well that's weird because like a lot of
like super high like celebrity actresses
and stuff like that are in their 40s and
50s and they still look amazing they got
some of their 60s and their 70s it
looked amazing yeah remember that one
[__] uh on the Shazam part two the
[__] British chick what's your name
the one that was played Morgana in
[__] in in yeah Helen Mirren Helen
mirror yeah I'm looking at her and she's
what 74 maybe she's probably in her 70s
yeah I imagine I was I was commenting to
Jan I was like man I can't believe that
she's held together so well man she's
hot she's definitely older but she's hot
I always like Helen mirrors yeah I mean
she was super cool I don't know she
looks without her clothes off but it
doesn't matter because there's something
about
when you have a woman who's attractive
like that she's in her 70s it's almost
kind of like she's earned it yeah it's
like yeah you know you kind of be a
little bit more forgiving to her you
know what I mean it's just
and then there's like a
if you score that it was almost kind of
like [__] street cred behind it you
know what I mean that's I think you know
what I mean there's it's like having sex
with the queen
but not like the actual Club
but like like a like a good one right I
get it
Zach says uh Isabella pear is hot as
[__] and she's almost 70 I think I
always thought isabelly pear was so
[__] sexy I always loved her and she
always I love her because she's a French
actress I don't know if you probably you
probably you might recognize her if you
are I've seen like a bunch of her movies
but I always like that
I mean she will be in some
[__] up movies man like she'll she'll
takes like some crazy roles and I
respect that you know what I mean I
really do like she really seems to
uh she really seems to be like into like
the craft of active which is kind of
like I said more a European thing yeah
yeah Tammy said Helen Mirren is 77 77 so
nearly 80. she was hot go look go watch
that movie now I'm sure they might have
done a little bit of CG on her it
doesn't matter
um she's still recognizable she looked
just like that like kind of likes to you
definitely recognize her from Excalibur
I grew up with hang on I want to see
that one again I love that movie I
always liked it I love Excalibur I
remember watching that in school isn't
that crazy like we watched that in our
English class because we were talking
about like Arthurian Legends and like my
teacher was like yeah let's watch that
Excalibur even though we were like kids
yeah but you know Excalibur and zardos
same director both good
Zarda is as weird as hell uh actually
man that's [__] kind of come true
Elites that want to wipe out mankind so
they can be the next step in the in
human evolution that's they got that out
of a bunch of [__] type of un type
papers think tanks and [__] we're
thinking like that
same kind of [__] uh uh Blade Runner and
[__] alien is talking about the
Weyland Corporation
yeah Zach said also God damn is she
stylish as [__] Isabella Parish talking
about now one of the best dressed people
I've seen anywhere yeah she always looks
like isabelly bear okay yeah she always
looks like super but like I said French
you do so they some the French I don't
know man they somehow seem to have some
kind of like classy [__] [__] that
like nobody else
seems to be able to do I'm not really
sure Sandra Peterson is still smoking
hot
you know you guys know where is Elvira
she's still smoking huh
um
that damn [__] scream Queen is
near 60 and she's still what's her name
uh the one that was from [__] uh from
Beyond and uh Barbara Barbara Crampton
she's yeah Barbara crampton's got some
great legs I'm on her Instagram yeah
yeah and she looks incredible yeah like
because she posts pictures of it and she
is like so [__] cute man because she
will post and she's always making that
big happy like smiling face like that
she makes and she's like so so cute but
it's like you you would never believe
that that woman is as old as she is
she's got a great she's not old she's
got a great ass with [__] great legs
she seems like a lovely person honestly
she's that which yeah she's still I just
saw a movie when did that movie came out
it was an indie horror movie what's it
called beyond the gates I think it was
called and it just came out when did it
come out a few years ago well it was
probably like longer than that it's
probably like 2016 or 2018 or something
like that and she was in that and like I
said she didn't look old at all she
played like a horror host type character
like that was on this videotape because
it was set back in the 80s you know what
I mean back in the 80s or 90s and she
was like on this VHS game and I was like
oh [__] you remember those remember
those [__] VHS games
that you that you'd put like the tape in
and it was kind of like a Choose Your
Own Adventure kind of thing and do you
remember those
there's a VHS Choose Your Own Adventure
uh well they had VHS games you know what
I mean that's a long time ago I remember
yeah they played a couple episodes yeah
yeah back up to a certain time yeah like
what are you gonna do like you know go
fast forward to this kind of thing it
had books like that well I had yeah I
had a bunch of the Choose Your Own
Adventure books choose your event yeah
they were kind of like Dungeons and
Dragons type the ones I used to get yeah
they're mostly like fantasy type stories
yeah and then you know you'd have a
decision like at the end of this chapter
if you want to do this turn to page
whatever you know what I mean so it was
like interactive but uh but yeah it was
like an old tech there I used to like
those though I used to have a whole
bunch of them they wrote like a [__]
bajillion of them
I used to get them out of the library
sometimes too
but uh but yeah those they've they've
played some of those VHS games on uh
beer and board games sometimes yeah it's
another good Channel which is which is
another yeah yeah I always watch beer
and board game well it's um blame
society but he does beer and board games
and welcome to the basement which is
like a movie yeah review show so I watch
both of those that's a really good show
I read we we both recommend that one
yeah blame society yeah beer and board
games is just it's four guys or four
people like I said it's girls sometimes
too but um sitting around playing it's a
different board game every week and they
sit around and sometimes they get really
drunk and it's like super funny
that's how we name Pookie yeah Pookie's
originally it was baby Cookie baby
Cookie was a character off of [__] the
blame society yeah she was a little doll
like a baby doll this little baby doll
it was naked he was like always yeah she
was three when she three no she was a
baby yeah but how old was she supposed
to be though three baby age
yeah but also she was um she did all
kinds she smoked yeah she uh [__]
talked [__] she raft down the gutter
she lived with her boyfriend baby Petey
she did all kinds of [__] also also
drugs right yeah she did drugs yeah
she's a pretty cool baby yeah she's the
baby
she spoke fluent Ebonics
she did everything yeah she she doesn't
turn up on every single show but she
usually does turn up on some of them but
yeah it's like that's super funny
but yeah so yeah I like that show too
there's a I I really like a lot of um
YouTube shows yeah I mean those ones we
already said brain attend old I like I
also like Ryan Hollinger
um who's an Irish guy and he talks about
horror movies and um don't forget [__]
case Cinema and [__] case Cinema yeah
he's a British guy he just taught he
doesn't do horror movies well he does
horror movies sometimes but he usually
does action movies like Ninja movie
stuff and man he finds like scrapes the
bottom of the barrel he finds like the
worst of the worst yeah and he also does
like a bunch of those Steven Seagal like
direct video ones which are real brain
and Neil yeah he does like a lot of Neil
bring movies too like and not super
funny but um he's his delivery is just
very funny great great writing right
dialogue [__] hilarious so he's like
but uh yeah he doesn't post his office
classic he doesn't post as often as he
used to like now he only puts up every
couple he's got a day job I think I
think he does too yeah he's a novelist
also and I keep saying I'm gonna like
buy some of his books I probably should
but um yeah Zach says Ryan Hollinger is
so cute my dream man looks like him yeah
he is adorable and his like his little
Irish accent is just like so cute and I
like that so many people commented on
how cute his Irish accent was that it's
like now he's just kind of like leaning
into it I think he even sells a t-shirt
in his store that says Hoy ever on it
because that's kind of how he pronounces
like every time because so many people
like commented on how cute it was like
how he pronounces however so I think
he's even got a shirt that says boy ever
wish I did that like made me laugh but
yeah
so like I said I like that I like Jade
the Libra like I said she does she does
kind of just like daily vlogging type
stuff but her main thing is Halloween
stuff like she'll go out like Halloween
hunting like for Halloween decorations
and she always like decorates her house
so like the inside of her house and she
has like a Halloween tree and [__] like
that and then she sometimes she does
clothes that could like you know scary
clothes and [__] like that and costumes
and um yeah like and um who else I'm
trying to think I like nexbo
that's um if you haven't seen that he
usually talks about like args stuff like
that like that
um he usually does roll in depth kind of
stuff he doesn't put out that much stuff
I think it's probably like every couple
weeks or something and I like a lot of
True Crime ones too I like True Crime
stuff I like scary stories
um you know I like Mr nightmare I like
although I think my favorite of all the
scary stories just as far as delivery
and like voice and stuff is Busta he's
um I think he's Australian and he will
usually put out a video it's like feel
like it's once a week or once every week
and a half or something like that and
it's usually like two or three hours
long and it's just like a compilation of
like story like scary stories that
people send him and it's like I've
actually
started listening just on my long
commutes and stuff
sometimes I'll listen to music like
Spotify but sometimes I'll listen if he
puts out a video that's like two or
three hours long like I'll spend like a
couple days like back and forth like
listening to that because I just like
the scariest especially if it's like
creepy and rainy outside or like in the
morning if it's kind of dark it's like
kind of cool like listen to the scary
stories and Camp guy said also cooking
channels yeah I like those too and you
do you know what's weird about it I
really like and I don't know why this is
but I really like I don't necessarily
like the people sometimes because they
seem like like they wouldn't be the kind
of people I'd hang out with but I do
kind of like this little subset of the
cooking channels that are always like I
made you know a Thanksgiving dinner for
ten dollars out of Dollar Tree or do you
know what I mean like because I'm just I
like the creativity of how they have to
go and spend only five dollars or only
ten dollars at Aldi or Dollar General or
whatever it is and like make something
good out of it like something about the
challenge of that is like really
appealing to me so I do like watch a lot
of those days oh
there's a couple different channels
that um
that do [__] like that I can't even
remember the name of them right now
but yeah so I like those too like
usually the challenge ones where you
have to like
but like you have to eat on a week for
like five dollars or something like that
I like cooking come Claudia real good
Mexican recipes
she'll teach you how to make hot sauce
even everything real good
Claudia
and I've really gotten into you just
lately like sometimes before I
you know just while I'm kind of like
winding down before I go to sleep or
something like that I've really gotten
into that weird history Food Channel
yeah that's good too like those videos
they they put up a [__] ton of videos
Man
but um they're usually like 12 to 15
minutes long and they kind of go into
like they'll either do something like
kind of wide ranging or like super
specific they'll talk about like one
fast food chain for example or they did
a whole video I watched one the other
day about the KFC double down which like
the history of the double down which I
thought was funny
uh Zach says I love internet
investigator she's this British chick
with a real deep voice who does videos
about internet internet-based horror
stuff and Mysteries deeper than Jen's
voice
hey it's no hey I'm just [__] with
you yeah it was not David Orr
um no it isn't it's not as deep as it
was
yeah well because I told them yeah it's
you still got a little bit of that grit
to it because uh yeah because of all
this you start frying all this all this
[__] that I'm on yeah for a while and
like my voice got all yeah Winstrol did
that
and I was kind of worried that it wasn't
going to go back no it's reversible
because it didn't well I didn't really
realize it that much until
uh I went back and watched one of our
old videos
my voice sounded completely different
like a little child and then one of our
friends said something about it too
angel angel says yeah because she she
watches our videos yeah well she wanted
to go on gear yeah I said yeah you
better go and get your fat ass then
she's like yeah but look what it did to
her voice and I said that's that's
reversible you just stopped taking it it
goes back
I mean there are women that have gone
full
transsexual and become he looked at it
as men you know
and then gone back to female and they
their voice goes pretty much go back to
normal they're still I'm really not I'm
not that bothered no you're with you're
you're well in the female range
you're well in the female rage
I like to I watch that what as I watch
don't fall on me now
I like to think I sound kind of sultry
yeah it's like a Kim Carn like Kathleen
Turner yeah yeah Daddy Dave is that
I'm not that bad I mean holy crap
it's just raspier yeah yeah that sounded
like some [__] yeah that's a three
pack a day happy yeah that's what that
sounds like yeah I don't think I sound
that bad but I don't know it's I don't
know what my voice sounds like to other
people
you know
although you well I guess I do because I
do actually have to listen to myself
yeah talk all the time because I do go
back and edit videos and [__] like that
that I talk in so I guess I'm just kind
of used to it yeah it did change a
little bit but yeah I did well like I
said I didn't really notice it until I
went back and watched one of our really
old videos and I was like oh I guess my
voice does sound a lot different yeah
but it's still in it's still in the
female rage there's a lot about you
that's changed since then you know I'm
not gonna mention it but [__] there's
a lot you know he's not gonna mention
I'm not gonna imagine what's stopping
you
he thinks about your physique
um it's androgens do that
that's the thing is is that it's not
unique all them [__] hotties that
we're talking about in their 50s and 60s
and 70s are all on gear they just use
different ones a different time
next one you ought to look at once uh
once you run once you go through [__]
mpps you want to [__] look at Primo
you've done that one before
yeah I remember you talking about it
yeah Tammy said Why Stop Now That's What
I said it's like like not like you know
talking about random [__] like all this
he said oh I'm not gonna say like what
else yeah but
I think I know what you're thinking
about yeah but
yeah certain [__] development
[Laughter]
the way your booty's shaped too is also
changing like for the better
yeah booty shape yeah your booty [__]
you get you're getting [__] bigger
legs bigger booty it's nice yeah
[__] fits better
I have noticed that yeah
it won't take long
just got to get everything right It's
gotta be within safety parameters
yeah I don't want like I don't want it
yeah you go too fast it's fun it'll [__]
you up you gotta go slow yeah you're
right and you gotta [__] do physical
stuff along with it to develop and then
uh because you know if you guys are new
to the show I don't know but me and Jen
also got a thing going on on a stream
mate so
we're both models too
we got a lot of video [__] made and
[__] just that it hasn't been released
yet
I have them all uploaded I just haven't
braced them in priced them yet made them
available
and um
we got fans leads going you haven't
heard from fansley have you not yet you
got on though right yeah I'm on we both
got on the street mate but and we have
streamed one time on there yeah just as
an experiment but we weren't on that
long because we were really tired so we
just wanted to see like how it worked
and so yeah certain select certain
select people in the comment section
here have hacked actually I've sent them
samples some [__] raw but footage of
[__] that we cut and looking everybody
seems to be happy with it
so uh yeah we usually work on stuff
every weekend yeah you know what I mean
we'll do his videos and photos it's fun
to make content
we're getting offers from [__] girls
we know [__] yeah you know maybe I'll
come by and make some content with it
and he wants to make content Bree yeah
Bree wanted to make a Content I haven't
seen her in a million years and then she
came out like yeah for the last momentum
I was like holy [__] girl my ex Carrie
never carry yeah that's from wave way
back that was like when venue 13 was in
DeLand yeah yeah I remember that Carrie
[__] thinks you're [__] smoking
hot she wants to make contact with
wants to make [__] content with you
but she's gained too much weight We're
not gonna bring cake carrion
well okay too late you just
did oh no I told her to her face oh
that's I told her I said I said no
[__] uh
you got to get yourself in shape
she she is working out though
she she wanted to go she was going on
gear and everything
um trying to see what who else want to
make content well it late to my ex later
of course she's like yeah I'll make
contact with you
yeah uh we'll see so yeah I think we
brought that up on the show on Wednesday
like maybe I don't know if people would
think that was weird or not that I
thought it was hilarious that you're
like setting stuff up it's like he's my
ex-girlfriend I'm gonna have my
girlfriend my girlfriend my
ex-girlfriend yeah yeah
I mean you know whatever well they do
that anyway well like I said she's my
friend too yeah
like obviously you knew her before I did
but yeah
Atlanta does that anyway
yeah they already do that right these
are all her and her husband yeah yeah
yeah it's really not
it's not that unusual
yeah I was like whatever
probably about one one quarter of all
the people that we know are somehow
doing this
and in the god scene and and out of that
one quarter the ones that are doing it
it's like 70 of all the hot people yeah
are also doing this
I mean might as well
they make money that's what I mean if
you gotta have a side hustle there's
like a lot there's I'd rather do that
than like deliver pizzas or something
right yeah
yeah and some of them are escorting
they'll see I don't want to do that yeah
no no thanks you know who they are
though yeah yeah I know but I'm just
high-end I'm just saying that yeah
um like I said that's another cool thing
about the internet is you can actually
like put up all this kind of content and
stuff like that but you don't have to
like actually interact with real people
which is nice let me tell you all
industry secret some of these [__]
really gorgeous
actresses that [__] work in these
named theme parks around here escort
strange as it is but that's that's like
I said girl got to pay rent somehow yeah
this ain't paying the rent that's
exactly what she told me you were
standing right next to me she goes that
[__] don't pay the rent right that's
what I'm saying yeah yeah and I would
never beverage anybody like making money
because I know how hard it is that's
right guys and the thing about it is
that
I don't I don't really have any kind of
um I don't have any any kind of judgment
about sex work of any kind because like
I said you know you're like yeah you can
make money another way you can drive an
Uber you can do this I was like yeah but
why yeah I mean to be honest like doing
[__] on streamate or like selling porn
that you made or something like that is
a lot safer yeah I feel like it depends
on the sex work I mean not escorting I
wouldn't do that you kind of have to be
like as well I'm not like [__] on
people that do do it because good for
you but it's like that's not for me all
those girls have a certain mentality and
you kind of don't want that mentality if
you ask me to [__] um
kind of the ATM mentality and they're
kind of like [__] distant uh I think
yeah yeah it's kind of they're kind of
depersonalized it too much if you ask me
I mean
but you know what I mean they're in
they're in their own situations I guess
uh yeah I mean everybody's coming out of
different like we were talking about
this the other day like to over text but
where he was saying that well some
people get to a point where they've just
done that kind of [__] so much like
their whole life that it's like sex
doesn't mean anything to them right and
it's like and I don't really want to be
that way yeah this [__] we do on a video
is between me and her and we're having
fun yeah we're in here like I said we're
just doing [__] that we'd be doing for
free anyways yeah yeah so it's like
we're just letting other people see it
and that's the only difference yeah and
then a lot of it is a lot of it is uh uh
[__] uh
okay when you're making this material
is staged you already have it planned
out what's gonna happen most of the time
we're gonna make this kind of video and
this and that you got a set of cameras
there's a lot of [__] you have to do
um it's it's not like normal sex
because you're worried about [__] like I
hope the audio is good you see what I
mean because when you're having sex
you're just [__] having sex but right
yeah there's a bunch of technical [__]
you're worried about and sometimes as a
guy it kind of throws you off you have a
problem [__] busting a nut because
you're worried about [__] technical
[__] yeah and then you go you know how
long has I been doing this and then
you're worried about what how long is
this long enough you know I didn't set a
timer
because we need to make a 15 minute
video this that kind of [__] is it well
yeah and I think about that should I
[__] actually [__] finish this
scene you know even though you really
shouldn't be worried about it because
you can edit it to whatever yeah length
you want well it took me a long time to
actually get through like even when I'm
just doing regular non-sex videos
um it took me a long time to get past
the thing it's like because I'd be you
know recording like a movie review or
whatever the [__] and then I would get
mad like when I [__] up and then I was
like oh duh I can just like edit that
out you know what I mean it's just like
I don't know why I'm [__] worrying
about it yeah so you
we're still at the stage where we've
that where we cause our own pressure
yeah well that's kind of my whole deal I
wish I wasn't like that because that's
but that's just what I'm like you know
how I get like and I start getting
overwhelmed to panicky and [__] like
that right and I really wish I wasn't
like that but and then stream mate the
shit's live right
so that's additional pressure
so
there's ways around it
but uh what what I do is you go on there
and you go look at other couples and see
how they do it
yeah because I was noticing there's all
kind of ways you can like work around
the rules because streamate now and I
was I listened to like this girl who had
been doing streamate for a long time and
she was like talking to this other girl
who was like just getting into it she
was like giving her advice and stuff and
it was actually like really good she had
like a lot of really good pointers and
stuff but apparently streamate and I
think like a lot of live streaming
um these kind of like sex worker lives
live streaming sites they have to be
really uh diligent
just so they don't get their ass in
trouble right like everybody has to be
everybody appearing on film you know
they have to have all your ID and your
address and everything like that so they
can make sure everything is above board
nobody can appear that they don't know
who it is all this other kind of [__]
you can't just have people wander in
they said they're even weird about
they're like if you're doing [__] on
your live stream or whatever and like
your dog keeps wandering it even if the
dog's not doing anything they're like
they're even kind of weird about that
because it's like oh there's an animal
in there and like we can get in trouble
right even though it's like they're like
yeah they're not gonna have a big deal
if like the dog just wanders in and then
wanders out again but if the dog is like
just hanging out there then like yeah
you might have to do something about
that but it's like they have a thing
where
in the free chat because like anybody
can come in and
um you know go in your room or whatever
and they can watch you doing what you're
doing like your live stream but it's
like you're not allowed to show anything
in the free chat like I said you can
show tits
um you can show like dildos and [__]
like that and you can blow them and yeah
you can do stuff like that but you can't
um you can't show like a real dick you
can't show any penetration you can't
show although I must say that in the guy
section but sometimes you do see people
yeah yeah you're breaking the rules and
[__] but they're get there's almost
there must be leeway for them guys maybe
or they're just thinking because the and
I don't know if the rules are different
because the the YouTube video I was
watching with that girl on it that was
like a year or two old but she said well
she had broken the rules a couple of
times like not intending to and they
said oh well they just suspended me for
like 24 hours or 48 hours or something
like that she's like but then they just
reinstated me after a few hours anyway
so the thing about it is that maybe yeah
they'll suspend you but maybe they
reinstate you really quickly so they
figure it's worth it well it could be
yeah it could be those dudes only stream
a couple times a day anyway right and
like and they're just kind of like
banking on nobody noticing because I
thought they were pretty strict about
about Noble no below the waist it says
like you can't show any nudity below the
waist
um in your free thing like it's
obviously like if people pay and like
you go into a private session then yeah
you can show whatever you want but so
they have like pretty strict rules about
that but then like when we went when we
just scrolled through there randomly
like on Saturday or whatever I'm like
well [__] there's all kind of people
like breaking the rules in there but
some people had like pretty clever ways
of like skirting it where it's like it
was just like subject suggestive like
you could tell what was going on but you
couldn't actually like see anything you
know what I mean so I was like oh that's
a good idea like maybe we should like
look into doing that but honestly to
to be honest like 99 of the time like
whenever I just randomly like you know
fire it up and like scroll through there
and like look at whatever the live
streaming people are doing 99 of the
people are just like sitting around not
doing anything and some of them are like
aren't even talking like to the people
and I you know what I mean so
I don't know I I just feel like if
you're gonna be on at least you have to
kind of like be entertaining I would
feel like but a lot of them aren't a lot
of them are just kind of like sitting
there so
uh Oscar says Sinister Cinema is a great
horror reviewer yeah I think I've
watched a couple of that
Tammy said oh I get to see Tom's tits
right
yeah you can see all you can see all
kind of time
[Laughter]
let's see uh oh Zach said you could
literally do an only fans of just feet
picks for five dollars a month and see
it come rolling in I and don't think I
haven't considered that you know what I
mean like maybe just doing a foot
Centric one because how easy would that
be just take pictures of it yeah I just
have to make sure that my toenails are
painted nice that was Zach saying that
yeah
Zach you have to see the statistics
though all right
um
it's only like the top one percent that
are making really good money all right
on only fans
only fans you sell in videos and
photographs I don't even think you can
stream live on only fans yet you can on
fansly yeah which I don't know why you
would want to it'd be better just you're
gonna stream live you do it on stream
mate
but um
99 of them are making somewhere between
300 or less
yeah
the top one percenter making doing
really well if but if you look at the
top one percent they are physical
outliers
new girls
super hourglass
Triple H [__] natural boobs big old
booty
um or super fit uh or uh skinny huge
implants it's always something some kind
of a physical outlier something that's
striking
dudes like novelty and that top 100 that
top one percent or what I would call
novelty women
they're making all the money
dudes don't make that much money
the top
male earners are super jacked dudes
doing uh gay material
I don't think they're gay a lot of the
guys but they're making a gay material
like I said porn that's kind of if
you're a dude that's kind of the way to
go if you want to make any money if
you're a high-end
mail
and you want to make money
you have to do gay material because
women don't women don't pay women don't
pay
all right most women do not pay for porn
now stream mate you can stream live
whether you're a girl or you're a guy
and you're getting these male customers
off
it's mostly women and almost everything
on stream mate is kind of like oriented
towards female performers
they have couples
there aren't very many couples
then you go to the guys only section
there aren't that many guys if you're in
your region because I check all this I
have this part of my job I gotta see
what the demographics are at any one
time in the United States in the UK
there's only six guys working
that flow yeah and those dudes are dogs
um
I'd be in the [__] top 10 easily
if I did that I don't I don't really
plan to do that
but the thing is your solo
it's not like you're having sex with
anybody else you're just sitting there
making money yeah
um but a lot of those dudes are doing
[__] that I wouldn't do
um but the thing is the weird thing
about streamate is that the customers
know what's up they know that the
performers have limits
and there's something about the limits
that turn certain guys on
like for instance new girls that won't
do very much some for some reason turn
these guys on they want to be like the
first ones to get her to do something
yeah they'll spend a lot of money they
want to corrupt her yeah like well
nobody else has seen this one you know
yeah so it's like a new thing so they
keep kind of trying well will you do it
for 200 right well if you do it for
three yeah so
that's something that you don't have in
video
somebody like
a couple like me and Jim really would
not make any income on video not not
enough to pay any bills
you make sound but that's not enough to
the money for us would be streaming yeah
because to make money or you know we got
friends in the industry to make money on
video you got to have a lot of videos
and you and it takes about a year or so
to get a return on the costs to make
that video
because you had to hire other performers
you had to uh [__] do testing okay
and then you had to get
locations which might be hotel rooms and
all that [__] adds up it's going to cost
about
six seven hundred dollars to make a
video
well that's about how long it takes
online to get a return on that
you got to make a lot of them
hundreds of them and
might take a year or so before you start
to see all that money coming back to you
it's going to be that much
700 a month
you got 300 videos out there making only
700 a month that's not that much
so the money is really in streaming live
live performance
which like I said that was kind of more
the aspect that I was kind of more into
anyway we are making videos yeah like
just to have some stuff up in the store
sell that to customers right yeah like
we do like I said every weekend we do
video shoots we do photo shoots we do
all so we have like a lot of material
but we're just kind of like laying the
groundwork for that just so we can get
more into the stream right and you know
like that that for that first trial
stream that we did had some guys ask me
for some [__] that I didn't [__] they
wanted to [__] solo [__]
performance and the thing is is [__]
what they're what they were specifying
is difficult to do with a drop of a hat
what's easier is to have videos to sell
them so if you want to see that it's
cheaper just to buy the video yeah you
can get the video for 10 15 bucks if you
want me to do that live [__] that's
going to take time that's going to be
about a hundred dollars they'll take the
cheaper route
yeah so we wanted to have like a good
variety of videos so that if somebody
came on streamate and were like hey we
want to see you guys do this or you want
to see you do that or whatever and we
can't do that for whatever reason then
we can say hey but we have a video of us
like that's you know ten dollars or
whatever ten dollars fifteen dollars
because if you want that [__] live
that's you know this [__] 4.99 599
699 a minute yeah that's going to take
[__] 20 minutes 30 minutes a half
hour
that's several hundred dollars yeah so
you can actually just go on stream at
Hawk videos
yeah and socialize with people
yeah which like I said that was kind of
what I was planned on doing I was just
kind of like doing like I said a show
like this but
you know
I don't know we always ask the gig they
can we can probably stream tomorrow at
some time yeah we'll see
we can I imagine we can
this is the guys are interchangeable as
the camp guys they just sit around
what he says and when they get another
boner they tap back in with the director
yeah
yeah the thing about it and the thing
about stream mate is that I know that
you're trying to like lure people into
your room and like getting them to
interact with you so they'll give you
some money and [__] like that but to me
it seems
I don't know I don't know if it seems
like good that because like I said we
we're scrolling through like the dudes
that were doing it like solo and like
some of the dudes are just like sitting
there like jacking and I'm like is that
do you really want to like show all of
that because it's like now you got
nothing left to do really like why would
anybody pay to see where they could just
watch you doing it for free and like I
said you're not really allowed to do
that anyway like sometimes you'll get
suspended
like if they catch you but people do
seem to get away with it though I
noticed
what was he talking about
I said it seems to me that if you are
hoping to get people to pay you yeah
um it would behoove you to not show too
much in the free yeah area like you know
tease people obviously and they have a
thing where like streaming has a thing
where it's like people can tip you like
ten dollars or whatever like oh show
your tits or whatever and you can do
that in the in that room but if you want
to do anything more explicit they have
to like gotta be exclusive you have to
go to like a private thing A lot of
people are just making money but just
doing stupid stunts in in in the free
chat
here's 10. if I can do this here but
it's it's like you know above the way
[__] and it's just [__]
that's what I mean it's like [__] if you
can just make money doing that I mean
that would be like pretty easy because a
lot of that stuff's like pretty easy
yeah like you don't have to do anything
like yeah this is strenuous
or anything like that you just selling
fantasy right
I mean yeah what was it gonna say about
uh [__] before I left we were talking
about they talking about those dudes
um I think sacrosan what does Zach say
about the dudes or [__] say what you
will but to me it seems like dudes have
the most fun making porn real dudes and
professional
uh we're not I think the the girls do
too
um depends yeah well they're in that
industry if they're in you know and
like I said
I know a guy who has a local Studio here
and we we talk a lot and about about the
business
and um he said I met gay dudes he said I
met gay dudes oh yeah
Maybe
but the women
this is this includes the guys too
no matter how much they're making
on porn with those uh Studios
those that those porn videos are really
most of the time not all the time but
most the time that's just the
advertisement for the escort servicing
yeah okay they're escorting and they're
sugaring you know that's what they're
doing a lot of it is off of Twitter
um they gotta be cool about it and not
be real obvious but I mean just the
stories you hear you know you got some
dude
he's basically a mope which is a great
move if you guys want to see a movie
about a porn industry see mope
and it's based on a true story one of my
favorite movies I want to have it I want
to own that movie
I'm gonna go buy that [__]
um a lot of times you know mope doesn't
make a whole lot of money and then he
keeps showing up with new cars and
[__] new clothes you're like where
the [__] is don't worry about where that
[__] came from because they're [__]
escorting man
and I tell you what it's not a woman
that didn't pay him that okay a woman
didn't pay for that a dude dude like I
said I don't know a single woman that
that pays for more no like I said now
women will buy erotica yeah they'll buy
like books like yeah that are like
they'll buy erotica well you know my
werewolf [__] muscle body looking uh
one in our [__] sells me [__] every
now and then
yeah he's escorted
yeah uh but he's escorted with females
right
and I was asking when I even saw his
clients some of them
and I was like what the [__] this how
they do that is very different male
escorting is very different from
female escorting
his clients were just uh business women
yeah again their 40s or 50s I had made
six figures but they just couldn't get
boyfriends so really what he was is he
was more like a secret agent he would
pretend to be a boyfriend from another
from another [__] company
yeah so you have to impersonate because
she's taking the [__] skiing
you know what I mean around her friends
so he has to pass himself off right as a
[__] executive from another company
that she's dating yeah he can't just be
something he can't be something dudes I
feel like they'll just like pay for some
skanky some skanky [__]
yeah yeah that's not the deal with women
are like yeah we want to be discreet
about that [__]
male escort has to be basically James
Bond he has to impersonate a [__]
civilian like you have to be like a real
person you can't just like be yeah you
have to improve yeah you can't like give
people the impression that you had to
pay for that exactly exactly because the
one I get it the woman would be
embarrassed of that yeah and here's the
thing is is that these are not for some
reason I don't know yeah
um well it's kind of belittling a
woman's [__] uh [__] prowess I
guess that she had to pay for it but the
thing is that she's not paying for the
sex
she's not paying for the sex she's
getting the sex for free basically
uh what she's paying for is [__] his
time and like uh because she's gotta
compete against his the other women that
are trying to get him to right come over
um the
uh well [__] I forgot about where I was
going with it
um
there you usually it's not usually like
a one-night stand thing with them yeah
it's like come skiing with me for two
weeks yeah and you have to have a bunch
of skills you gotta learn how to ski
you don't know how to ride horses yeah
you can't you can't be late you can't be
lame you gotta be like James Bond right
you know and really what he what she's
done is she's hired a vehicle to brag to
her friends
you know yeah look I got a man but she
can't get a man she's a boss [__] she's
somebody's boss
and um she can't go the guy who makes
less money than her than her and she has
to go out with a guy who supposedly
makes more money than her like a catch
but the dudes that are all making more
money than her going out with a chick
from [__] Starbucks
because guys don't care how much much
money a woman makes she just cares why
not guys just care whether she's got a
[__] tight ass and she's got a good
wreck and is she fun
so
career women actually especially if
they're tall
[__] uh [__] have a uh problem
finding guys yeah I can see that so they
try to
to hire these guys to be fake boyfriends
for [__] outings
to show off to their friends
[__] sad but true
um well I don't know I don't think it's
any more sad than the reverse though I
just think it's sad This Woman's paid
all this money for the [__] education
she's making all this money and then
she has such limited dating options that
she needs special that's only sad
because dudes are the worst
no dudes aren't the worst it's just
dudes aren't really gold diggers they
don't care how much a woman makes they
just care whether or not they like her
and they don't
like
if they liked her she wouldn't have to
be doing this you know it
so no you can't blame a guy guys are
attracted to what they're attracted to
yeah and her standards are too high too
oh yeah she can't go out but the thing
about it is dude that makes less money
than her and she makes [__] 250 000
300 000 a year but I feel like a woman
that was educated and made 250 000 it's
like why did you even need a dude don't
waste your money on that [__]
just go do fun [__] by yourself yeah
that gets old evidently
I mean you don't need that [__] you
don't need that aggravation
foreign
I mean the thing about it is that
I don't know I I don't know if I so much
uh because I know that was that was age
that [__] book whenever it was
the 90 went back about the 90s and I
know that that was very much in the
Zeitgeist at the time it was just like
this whole Battle of sex is thing and I
do feel like some of those ideas have
Merit but I don't know I think we're a
lot more similar than we are different
but there are definitely differences
though
oh [__]
did we lose it
okay it's back yeah we've been uh I
guess because it's storming outside
our uh stream has been kind of
intermittent
I don't know if you guys are noticing
but I'm noticing because I can see my
little light going yellow and then red
but it came back to green so hopefully
you guys can still hear me
yeah Tammy said Dudes Only care what a
girl looks like I mean to a large extent
that's true although I think that
usually well I don't know if I want to
say that I thought it's like it mostly
applies to younger men I feel like
because once dudes get older
sometimes
um they do kind of get more mature but
not always so you know
yeah and we've said and we've said this
before too I do feel like
women are a lot more
um
they're a lot more wide band a lot more
forgiving of looks if the dude has
something else to offer you know what I
mean yeah women aren't really uh
that's not the primary not really for
men it is yeah well that's all visual
that's what Tammy was saying yeah it's
like they only care now look man I've
been there before the uh [__] even in
my 20s and 30s where you score some
chick and like visually she's like a 8.5
she's [__] gorgeous she opens her
mouth and you can't [__] stand her
all right you're like God this this
[__] is [__] driving me up a [__]
wall dumb just [__] Dumber oh man
she's evil you can beat anything you'll
hit but you'll try to get rid of her
it wears off very quick very quickly so
dudes aren't that dumb yeah they're not
that dumb
some guys are like yeah yeah she's
[__] gorgeous she [__] sucks
though I'ma [__] this for about a month
and then I'm gonna get rid of her
which we do that too
because you don't have anything else
going on right
just because she's hot you're [__]
her doesn't mean you like her yeah
you're a man you're there to impregnate
a [__] that's what you're
programmed to do it's true
I have a hard time and I'm you know and
I know that not all women are like this
because I've had some friends that were
not
um that they could absolutely like hate
[__] somebody yeah um I can't do that
and I know and I know a lot of women
can't but a lot of people but I've known
women that could do it yeah and I'm just
like well fair play to you I can't do
that I can't I can't have sex with
somebody I don't at least like no one no
one has said [__] to remain nameless
says that she would [__] the [__] out of
some
ugly [__]
and the reason why it's happened is
because
dude is so ugly that it makes her feel
gorgeous and she's getting off on it
I could kind of see that yeah well we
thought well like I said we talk about
this a lot we've been talking about a
lot more since we've like been getting
into the porn industry yeah right and
stuff like that so it's just kind of
like the weird Mind Games women will do
well that's what I keep telling you it's
just gonna do that she's ugly that's
what I'm saying it's just like women are
very very complicated it's like I know
and I know dudes have a hard time wait
[__] we can't even figure our own [__]
out I can't figure my own [__] out okay
women don't know what they want until
they see it I mean
I don't know if that's true but the
thing well it's not so much that it's
just that no it's not so much that it's
just that our standards are nebulous
yeah like you might have like standards
in your mind it's like oh if somebody
asked you you know what models you have
to be like what's your perfect man or
something like that like you know a
woman would give you like some stats or
whatever but it's like if they meet a
dude that doesn't have any of those but
he's like super cool or something like I
mean she might fall madly in love with
that so it's just kind of like so I feel
like sometimes too like dudes that maybe
don't interact with real women a lot
yeah it's like a Humanity yeah like
they'll go like on dating websites and
be like look at these shallow [__]
it's like with all of this thing but I'm
like dating websites make you put [__]
on there it's like this is what I'm
looking for I don't know what the [__]
I'm looking for I don't know you like
you could look like anything you could
be into anything like if I like you and
we connect then it doesn't really matter
and the juvenile manosphere I think
they're starting to [__] catch on to
that
they're disseminating that information
that the women to give stock answers
right because if you ask me like what's
your I don't have a type right what's
your ideal I don't know it's the same
thing I don't know here's something that
here's something that a guy would
understand
if your guy says [__] what's a hot
describe a hot chick you're gonna say oh
man she's got a [__] real narrow
waist got nice hips big old [__]
booty huge [__] titties on her she's
[__] going that's what you're gonna
imagine you're gonna say she's hot as
[__] but then you see a girl who does
not look like that at all and for some
reason you just think she's hot right
and she doesn't look like that at all
I'm gonna go for that one it's the same
she's skinny as a rail and [__]
nothing like but there's something about
somebody like right her haircut her face
what she said how she walks the clothes
she's got on [__] her personality you
know what I mean some guys who hold her
personality man you know what the [__]
you're talking about a woman's
personality is the main motivating
driver behind her [__] sexuality if
she got a shitty personality I got
pictures to prove [__] I've been with
nines before
all right especially when I was younger
but they sucked [__] terrible I'd
rank them at the bottom starfish out on
you just lay like that he didn't do
anything during sex it was just terrible
in bed some of them because they skate
on their looks the no skills no
personality at all but then you find a
girl who's physically she's like a 6.5
but there's just something about her
she's just so [__] into you and so
[__]
animated and [__] and just her
personality you know all of a sudden
yeah she's a 6.5 but she's a eight
really in total when you when you factor
in the other [__] magical factors
that the [__] has I mean the thing
about it is like I'm not saying looks
aren't important they are yeah but it is
a mixture a bunch of stuff you could be
like the hottest person in the world
yeah but yeah if you're just like this
blank charisma-free person then it's
like you might not get very far either
like you can get pretty far on your
looks I'm not saying that but it looks
and no Charisma just buy one of them
damn sex dolls that's what him and girls
were exactly like that right
well the thing about it is that like
yeah like some people that are super hot
not just women men too like some people
that are really really good looking they
never really had to work for anything
because they were good looking so they
kind of just got everything easily so
they didn't really have to do anything
else they didn't develop any personal
skills right they didn't have to like
have anything to back that up yeah I
mean you see that a lot sometimes too
like and sometimes you see this like
with uh you know people that were real
hot when they were younger and it's like
they got all these you know they got
boyfriends girlfriends whatever but then
like once they get a little bit older
and maybe they could they gain a few
pounds or something like that they don't
have anything to back it up and they're
not really cute anymore yeah so it's
like they can't really skate behind
their looks anymore and they don't
really have anything other than that
because they didn't have to develop
anything when they were younger another
thing that uh male escorts do is that
they escort for other escorts
they're either going to be some boss
[__] or they're going to be a hooker
because a lot of [__] escorts can't
have boyfriends
uh their
solo operators they're they live a
pretty lonely life they're moving from
one trick to the next doing their little
gigs and they can't be honest with
normal civilians about what they do for
a living
so they'll find a male escort that they
like and they'll have a a relationship
with that guy that they pay for
because they can be honest with that
dude yeah and then they can talk about
the business
yeah which is you can talk shop right
and uh the thing is though is that she's
got money she's going to pay if not
you're gonna go up with some other one
and then they from what I've heard then
all of a sudden they want loyalty
because it's in it's in a woman's nature
they to try to be in some kind of a
relationship they don't like these
shallow
transactions
and this is exactly what goes on in
Japan with those host bars
where they have all these super
if you ask me kind of a feminate looking
pretty boys
where girls pay money to go sit at a
table and drink with them all night be
entertained and sometimes they have sex
with them
those are not civilian girls those are
hookers
female hookers do business with male
hookers that's this
that that's the that's the economy
because a civilian girl is not going to
pay for that
yeah why would you yeah
they can get a boyfriend
hookers have a problem getting
boyfriends
they gotta go they gotta go to a
professional
who knows how to deal with them in their
problems
yeah I mean you know I I can feel it and
a lot of those guys I've seen interviews
with those male
hosts in Japan and they're nice guys
um and a lot of them feel really bad
about what they're doing because they
say here's the Dig
these girls are eventually end up
turning tricks to make all this money
to spend on these [__] male
prostitutes
they're not paying their rent they're
not doing it they're trapped in that
lifestyle right and they can't back out
of it
which I could kind of and the dude is
like I actually like this chick
I wish she would stop doing what she's
doing but she can't because she's
[__] gotta come see me yeah so I'm
kind of behind her turning herself out
and they kind of felt guilty about it
yeah even though like and he was in the
dude the dude that I saw his interview
he's like she didn't pay to have sex
with me she was paying to drink with me
and be my friend I actually was having
sex with her because I liked her but I
can't have a relationship with her I got
to pay bills too right
what's up
it's kind of a not a natural situation
well that's what I mean it's kind of a
shitty situation yeah yeah which like I
said that's why I mean even if I was the
kind of person that could do escorting
um it's just it was just complicates
everything too much even if I wanted to
do it which I don't because I'm
predictive I'd never allow it well I
wouldn't I don't want to do it anyway
yeah I would never allow I'm just not
that kind of person I've never been that
kind of person it's self-destructive
Behavior I wouldn't allow you I wouldn't
allow you to help well one it's
dangerous it's dangerous it's
self-destructive and it's uh no and like
I said you get into a thing where you
can't really get out of it yeah I feel
like because we know girls who did it
yeah one that I'm talking about sheet I
talked to her recently and she said
she's been in and out of it she can't
quit that's what I mean and she's got
that boyfriend and knows right but every
time she gets in trouble she goes out
and turns tricks and if you saw this
girl you'd never suspect yeah she's one
of those like she's like a yuppie she
looks like a yuppie she's totally fine
she's not a goth girl or anything no
you'd never suspect her see it's always
like it's a quiet one she looks like a
good one she don't they don't want you
to good girl
yeah she's a pro
Semi-Pro right now
and she's [__] up about it I said yeah
how's everything been uh pretty good he
says did you did you end up quitting she
goes no I backslide a lot whenever we
need money I I just do it I can't stop
it
that's what I mean once you get into it
and she made a lot of money doing it
yeah so it's like
what you know once you get into it and
it's like it's almost like I don't want
to say it's easy money because it's
addictive it wouldn't be easy for me
because it's like it sounds like one of
my worst nightmares to be honest with
you but
because it's just I don't know like I
said I I'm not gonna say I admire girls
that can do that it's not actually
admiration but it's just kind of like I
could never do that I just could never
do that it's just it's not me I mean you
know me I just like I'm not like that at
all no I don't even like hanging out
with people like for an extended period
of time like in a non-sexual fashion
more entertainers who are not that kind
of entertainer right that's right
there's got to be boundaries well yeah
and that's what I'm saying and that's
why the whole thing like you know us
doing stream Aid and stuff like that was
predicated on just us yeah doing it
together in the house yeah and it's like
you know yeah maybe eventually down the
road we'll bring in another girl or
something like that but it's just like
we weren't really like we're like we're
not bringing in a bunch of random ass
[__] I'm not like going out
like associating with random ass
[__] I just don't want to do
that and you look at the Democrats not
my thing if you look at the demographics
of the dudes that actually pay that make
it worthwhile to do that it's all 65
plus guys in other words these are
[__] Senior Citizens senior citizen
business owners
because they're safer they pay more
money they're nicer to the [__] girls
than they are the younger guys who kind
of treat women like [__] they're more of
a risk yeah
um if you look at like aiella
all of her customers are 65 plus yeah
eighteen hundred dollars the first hour
and then it goes down to like twelve
hundred dollars for every hour after
that
the dudes are all married and come with
references and [__] you know I mean
the wife's just shut them off years
years ago
so they're totally safe
and it cuts our workload down that's why
she does that well yeah because it's
like fewer people fewer people when it
pays more and you don't have to deal
with dudes that are at risk yeah I mean
not saying that like older dudes can't
be a risk as they can you never know
when they're gonna flip out on you but
still I mean you guys have too much to
lose it's yeah but yeah it's definitely
less than a rescue yeah yeah than some
[__] dude in their 20s or 30s and
they all come with references
they come with from another girl yeah
would you like to have it that's what I
mean you really date her unless you have
references and then she calls that
reference and size who it is and then
she looks at her online
profiles
entirely too much yeah well they become
regulars
that just sounds like a [__]
nightmare you don't want anything to do
with this that sounds like a nightmare
and then you gotta cater to that
[__] that's what I mean I'm not
good at that [__] yeah those [__]
[__] are into [__] just boring ass
[__] you know I don't want to take you
golfing and [__]
God
please kill me and you gotta pretend
like this shit's exciting that's what I
mean and it's like I'm not really good
at that I'm not good at like pretending
that I like [__] I don't like hey let's
go to like a college football game oh
God please just run me over with your
car instead it's like I just can't I
just can't I mean you know Tom knows me
he's known me for a long time I'm just
really really not good
like man if I really don't want to do
something and I don't and I don't like
doing any of that kind of like Normie
[__] I don't like doing any of that kind
of stuff so it's if I had to pretend to
like do like all that [__] yeah I'm not
good at that kind of stuff because like
even if I try to pretend it's like after
about 10 minutes I would get worn out
and I would just start getting all
sarcastic and then I would start like
having anxiety attacks so that's about
how that would go I'll just not like
that just not like that and that's what
I was telling them before I was like
that's why the only the only kind of
like
uh edible if you want to call it
escorting or like live action like sex
work I could do was like domination
dominatrix [__] where I didn't actually
like have to have sex with the dude I
could just like step on his balls or
like kick him in the nuts or whatever or
make him eat out of a dog bowl or
something like I could do that and like
abuse him and stuff I could do that but
it's like if I have to sit there and
like pretend
to be all into you and like pretend to
like [__] that you liked which is really
boring and it's like yeah I'm not good
at that kind of stuff I don't think I
could get away with that for five
seconds
so you know
so like I said this seemed like to get
what do you want another drink yeah how
long have you been streaming
um I don't know
two hours if you guys are having fun
[__] we'll uh continue if not we'll
[__] shut the [__] down I mean I'm
having fun yeah I'm fine okay
Camp guy said as a man at 61 I'm kind of
gobsmacked trying to figure out an older
woman
I'm not necessarily what
about having to try trying to figure out
an older woman oh
I'm not necessarily interested in
Intercourse but if I met an attractive
older Mission I would like to sit by a
big bonfire in cold weather and snuggle
up together without pressure
without pressure to have uh sex
I mean that sounds nice actually I just
wish it was cold enough here that I
could cuddle up by a fire but
we can't ever do that but you know what
I mean I don't know it's just
like I said it's kind of hard to say
because I don't
women are complicated man
we're complicated and I'm sorry I'm
sorry we're like that and we're and
we're we're all different we're all
complicated in a different ways
and like I said I know Tom was like
making a joke it's like they don't even
know what they want after it's like
that's kind of dismissive but in a way
it's kind of true but like I said I
think it's kind of true of dudes as well
I don't think anybody really knows what
they want
because
being asked in a situation like like I
said what your ideal thing is or what
you would like I mean yeah everybody's
gonna give their situation this that and
the other but that's never how it works
out in real life I mean I think that's
true for everybody
but like I said women are kind of
complicated
I don't even know what the [__] I'm
thinking half the time so
I don't know how anybody else has any
hope of figuring it out to be honest
it's like somebody says [__] how do you
define porn he says I can't Define porn
but you know when you see it it's the
same thing with [__] men and women
you can't really Define what they're
looking for but they know what it is
when they see it uh
a lot of it has to do with character
that's what I mean it's just kind of
like I mean when I was single
like after I after my divorce and
everything when I was out on the prowl
um
I you know the dudes I met that ended up
that I ended up hooking up with not
necessarily if somebody had showed me
like a photo lineup or something like
that like before I met them not
necessarily like maybe what I would have
picked I don't well I don't know but
like depending on what other photos you
would show me but it's like when I met
them there was something about them that
was like very attractive to me like if
you even depend like not really depend
on what they look like but just like
their personality was like or if they
were into the same kind of [__] as me or
something like that there was something
about them that was like attractive so I
don't know and I think that's true of
most people
what's that I missed part of it
look let me tell y'all Young Buck
something even you old guys
although a lot of you all guys probably
know this
dudes do not understand the power of
Mystery
shut the [__] up
don't talk to so [__] much all right
usually the less a woman knows about you
the [__] more attractive she is to
you
[__] now you have to [__] cover
certain base bass lines you gotta look
good you gotta look different than the
competition
you got to stand out don't talk so much
all right uh well I think that's true
across the board because I kind of wish
most people wouldn't talk to them yeah
let them wander
you attract oh no that's pretty funny
coming from us who just like yeah if you
tell everybody everything well we're
entertaining right now we're on the show
here just like talk about it I'm talking
about in a while yeah
Camp guy said yes that's good advice
yeah I mean who's my advice or your
advice I guess yours okay yeah well I
guess I don't know but I'm yeah I'm just
saying that
people yeah people in general talk too
much
too and they talk too much about
themselves also like especially when
they're trying to like get to know
somebody they're trying to say I'm okay
here this is what I do I'm okay trying
to get approval yeah
you don't want that either you shouldn't
really be worrying too much about it
well I think that's kind of another
thing and I think that was I think
that's what always made you
very attractive to women because you
always have been Tom has never had any
problem at all like getting attention
from women [__] man even last weekend
when we were at the when we were at
Ichiban at the Asian buffet yeah he's he
had some like older ladies like coming
up to him at the I was at the table like
eating and he was up there getting some
pot stickers old ladies coming up there
like asking for advice on what food they
should get and stuff like that and I'm
just like oh my God that's hilarious and
then another one he's always got the
ladies like and if I [__] keep
talking another one
for these old women like in their 60s
and 70s
asking me about the intricacies of
[__] pasta
try to jump on that d
that's not at that age that's not what
they're looking for well I don't know
about that they might be super horny
they mostly just don't want any kind of
attention or validation it's talk to me
talk to me talk to me yeah
tell me I'm pretty
yeah
you're not though babe you didn't
[__] hold together well I mean the
thing of it like ladies of all ages and
appearances yeah like feelings but well
everybody likes feeling special nobody
likes feeling like they're a nobody I
mean you know that's a pretty human you
know how I said earlier you said you got
women are 70s or 60s the hottest [__]
yeah they're out there but they're not
common
Asian buffet
yeah I mean I'm just saying we were
there last Saturday and I was like we
were you know by far the best looking
people in there man those people are fat
[Laughter]
I'm talking about seven of them me we're
in there and [__] like a family of
like seven came in
were they I think it was like a bunch of
co-workers because they all have the
same like uniforms no not those I was
talking about oh you're talking
it was a family of like
parents are there some grandparents some
parents and some children
and so uh they were white except one of
them was black
uh I don't know I think they were
related though
um
I don't think well done we lost the
stream for a second okay I think it's
back is it back I don't think a single
one of them was under 250 pounds I think
they were all at least 300 pounds
yeah they were they were all uh yeah
very large people yeah the cutest one
was probably 250.
yeah yeah
and I'm just like how's this I mean it
is an all-you-can-eat buffet it's all
you can eat buffets it's gonna attract
big people but
I mean not only were you the best
looking people in there I think we were
also the thinnest people in there yeah
by quite other than the employees yeah
the Chinese dude that worked there
[__] sees me he's like yeah yeah
we're just here for the protein yeah we
do for the protein
shrimps I'll sit there and eat a whole
[__] plate of shrimp hey Willie I
might need to eat some tomorrow we can
go to our local all you can eat buffet
the close one just to get shrimp the
cheap Chinese that you cheated with me
on tell them the story
tell the story I know exactly what Jay's
talking about JD's author good tell him
Jen yeah I might have told this story
before but it might have been like on
one of the other shows I'm at work right
I don't remember what day of the week it
was it was some [__] weekday
obviously it's like a Tuesday it was
like a Tuesday or some [__] like that
and I just get a random text like on my
phone while I'm at work and Tom said all
he said was
he said I'm cheating on on you with that
cheap Chinese chick and like I just I'm
sitting at my desk and I just busted up
laughing because it's like I knew
exactly like in seconds like what he was
talking about
he was talking about that closer what
the [__] is that place called I forgot I
can't remember the name of it it's the
Chinese it's a Chinese like kitty buffet
and it's the closest one to our house
because like I said we always get a koi
one Kentucky and we always get a koi one
but that's far it's like it's a long
drive it's like 20 something miles
and then we found Ichiban which is 18
miles and is a much easier drive so
we've actually been going to that one
and that was actually pretty good too
but there is one that's only eight miles
away but it's not quite as good and it's
not quite as extensive right I can't
remember even remember what it's called
but it's like so he just sent me that
text out of the blue and I just like
busted up laughing because I knew
exactly like what he meant like as soon
as he's so I'm cheating on you with that
cheap Chinese oh
well like I said whatever because we
always do that thing where because
sometimes you know because I work during
the week so I can't like you know be
home and I can't go anywhere so every
now and then like he'll go out to eat
and he'll just send me a text like I'm
cheating on you at like whatever it's
all food cheating yeah it's because I'm
like you [__] I'm sitting in my
95 degree car like eating crackers yeah
and you're like getting good [__] you
know what I mean but yeah
Tammy said I worked in nursing homes
some old people still want sex oh yeah
yeah and I've heard that some old folks
homes are just like [__] they're like
orgies Rife with STDs yeah like big time
uh because they're all like horny and
stuff what's my friend I get that
grafters knows who I'm talking about is
my friend up in Michigan his name is uh
[__] Mike Kowalski he owns a
a uh Ambulance Service
it got three or four ambulances and big
old [__] uh [__] paramedics he's
got a paramedic Service Company
and one of his regular customers is Old
Folks house he's in there all the time
picking up people as they're dying and
[__]
and he said that that place was like a
[__] orgy I've heard that he knew the
dudes had been in there for years who
were [__] slowly dying and living in
there and [__] he'd shoot the [__]
with him and like there'd be guys like
oh yeah yeah I [__] her and I [__]
that one and I [__] these [__]
either they'd be talking like they were
in the middle school yeah or High School
he's like oh yeah you hit that he goes
oh yeah she's that one's [__] sweet
there and I believe it they'd be
[__] and [__] and [__] the nurses
that try to break it up
and they would [__] lock the doors
and try to [__] keep why though
they're adults they're just the way the
the mentality I don't understand it they
think that they're out of it I guess
I mean maybe but as long as nobody's
getting like exploited they're not like
in there having sex with women that are
like [__] Mike's unconscious Mike
said that they would go in there in
teams like one dude would [__] stand
outside the door like like a lookout
another dude would be inside the door
hold the door shut
well the other guy was [__] cracking
his [__] girlfriend
okay so they have this all planted they
had a system yeah and they was like
straight up
no
we had they had a whole [__] system
of purity
like I said as long as no one is being
exploited as long as nobody has dementia
or anything like that all kind of had a
little bit I mean maybe but it does seem
like I don't know and I kind of feel
like that's why I kind of feel like a
lot of uh elderly people maybe don't
want to go to these homes because it's
like you kind of lose your dignity a
little bit and you're probably they
don't treat you like an adult anymore
yeah they treat you like a baby they
treat you like a baby I feel like oh
you're not allowed us like hey I'm a
grown-up yeah they couldn't have sex
that which is crazy you wouldn't allowed
to have sex
that's crazy to me it may not be like
that anymore that was a long time ago
yeah it was like back in the [__]
late 90s he was telling me that
I don't know but
like I said I I see what where they're
coming from with it like they're airing
on the side of caution yeah just in case
but it still does seem like these are
still adults yeah and if they have all
their faculties then
give them privacy like and let them do
adult [__] like adults would do you know
what I mean
um Tammy said we were taught we were not
allowed to stop them if they wanted to
have sex because they were adults well
that's good because that's what I was
just saying like I said as long as
nobody is like like being exploited or
this evidently was up in Michigan I mean
I know it was Michigan but evidently
Michigan might have different rules at
least they did in the late 90s
early 2000s I think when you told me
about that
so I don't know the situation it might
have been that they they were all kind
of like borderline deficient
yeah I mean well yeah maybe that was the
thing maybe they knew that those
particular people are like yeah well
they're not right so we really need to
like control what they're doing but
other than that I feel like if they're
just if they still have all their
faculties and stuff I don't see any
reason why you shouldn't just treat them
like a grown-up you know
at least I'm gonna happen to have let
them have some dignity Jesus Christ yeah
Ken Garcia says that they're five
thousand or ten thousand a month some of
them are yeah
um
Camp guy says um I'm still fairly
happily married oh talking about the um
hypothetical situation before about uh
finding a woman or whatever uh so I'm
just I'm still fairly happy married so
I'm just imagining a situation I did
have one occasion just last year where I
traveled to a conference by myself yeah
it's um
I don't know I don't think too much
about it to be honest with you it's
funny because me and Tom were talking
about this if you guys remember
how many years was this two years ago
now
uh it must have been two years ago so it
was two years ago I went on vacation to
St Augustine and I went for five days
and I went by myself
and
I had a great time actually I I went
there by myself and I just I stayed in
an Airbnb and I just went to all the
museums I went to the Lightner Museum I
went to the Pirate Museum I went to the
Ripley's Museum and it's like I ate
croissants and walked around and looked
at all the history and looked at all the
fort and stuff like that and it was like
super super fun
and I didn't really think anything about
it and then like later on
Tom said to me that he's that he had
thought he's like I didn't really think
that you had cheated on me but he's like
I was kind of thinking about like you
could have like because you were gone
all that time and I thought that was so
so funny that he said that because it's
like honestly
sleep different
it never occurred to me I was just
excited to like go there by myself and
like run around and do all this fun [__]
and it's just like that was literally
the last thing in my mind I did never
even occurred to me I just thought that
was so so funny
that he thought I just I said that's
kind of maybe the difference between how
dudes think and how women think
because that was literally
the last thing that was that I ever even
thought of you know
I missed it what are you talking about
oh I was talking about that um remember
a couple years back when I took that
trip to St Augustine yeah and then you
were telling me later that it's like oh
I was kind of thinking that maybe like
you'd had the opportunity to like cheat
on me or whatever yeah and it's like and
I just thought that was so funny because
I was like that literally like never
occurred to me like the whole the whole
time I was there I was like I would have
I was having such a a fun time it's like
oh but I go to the Pirate Museum I'm
gonna go look at all this I'm gonna go
eat some croissants yeah some fresh fish
or something like that it literally
never crossed my mind it really did it
it really didn't no you know guys can
interpret it like well she might be need
maybe she needs to take a break yeah you
know that that's but yeah I wasn't sure
I thought it was maybe 50 50. but it you
know really yeah that's just really like
I said that's funny that's like I didn't
hold it against you but like I said it
literally never occurred to me yeah it
literally never occurred to me I was
just like I said I was just excited I
was good I have a special relationship I
went we had a special like I said I was
just I was excited to go to all the
museums I would go to a lot of museums
all day I went to the alligator farm
that was super fun that was like most of
the day and then I would come back to my
Airbnb and I would lay in the bed by
myself and I would put MST on the TV
yeah and I would read a book and I would
drink a cup of coffee and then I would
go to sleep that's literally all that
happened Jen and I had been together
[__] like 24 7 for probably like
seven years
no more than that it will it was more
than that I think it was 10 years like
10 years right 10 years so she needed a
vacation yeah but you know what I mean
[__] a guy when a guy has a vacation
it goes somewhere you know I mean yeah
we we know how that is you know when
you're a guy
so
I thought it was a possibility I thought
you know but but I was like yeah she's
been good though you know she's back
she's bigger I just thought that was so
so funny you know I didn't know if she
was meeting somebody there might have
been a fan I don't know you know it was
really none of my businesses we're not
married
you know but I just thought that was it
so yeah I thought that was so funny that
you thought that because like yeah I
think that yeah I said I thought it was
a possibility oh okay yeah I didn't
think that you did anything but I
thought it was possible let me worry
about it literally networking wait you
mad I'm not jealous no no I just thought
it was I'm just pointing out like how
funny the difference was I wasn't sure
because that was I just needed a break
from
not not you necessarily but just from
this whole situation like because I've
been working so much and it's just kind
of like I was like I just need to get
away and also I kind of wanted to do
something what a guy's gonna do he's
gonna [__] somebody you guys can chime
in in the comments section
so every time you go someplace without
me is that what you mean no I'm saying
if a guy's gonna go on vacation
somewhere right you know what I mean
[__] Gonna Leave oh for a while to
get away from the there's gonna be
there's most likely going to be another
woman involved no I just mostly wanted
to do stuff that she's gonna be a pro
that I knew that you didn't really want
to do because it's like you don't want
to spend all day going to museums and
you don't want to spend all day you
don't want to do that kind of [__] but I
like that kind of yeah well you know
well so I want I wanted if the guy's
gonna do that he's going to make all
kinds of excuses you know what I mean so
I'm just I'm looking at it through a
guy's eyes I'm going back anything's
possible yeah anything's possible uh but
no if a guy's gonna do something like
that [__] it's and it's not going to
be it's not going to be [__] um you
know what I mean like somebody you know
like your sister or [__] or your best
friend or anything you shouldn't be it's
gonna be some professional most likely
you know but so I didn't know now women
don't operate that way but dudes do
yeah we know dudes do yeah but I just
thought that was kind of funny because
you want somebody who's not gonna tell
on you okay that's all it is and it's
just you somebody who's not going to
give you any problem that's guaranteed
you're gonna give her the money and
she's not gonna tell on you and then
she's gonna vanish
part of what you're paying her that's
why she you paid her to get her to get
her the [__] out of there you know you
don't want her to follow you
Tammy said Jenny cheated on you with a
pirate or an alligator yeah
that's not should I like have a video of
that
is being a pirate yeah sell that [__] on
stream mate I really do like the Pirate
Museum there I just I wish that it
wasn't
um so full of children that was the only
thing I probably shouldn't have gone in
the summer time that's probably another
thing I think if I go again I'll go in
winter
but um just because there was all the
kids were out of school and the Pirate
Museum as cool as it is is you know the
kids love that [__] so Camp guy says he
would not like to see an old man with a
boner [__] man [__] uh that shit's
all over that you'd be able to find that
easily um
depends on what their Wang looks like
yeah they got all kinds of they got all
kinds of movies with uh that that the
focus is real old dudes with [__]
real young women
you know
they got that out there old and young
porn there's a whole dude everything's
out there's a whole thing of that every
single thing you can think of and lots
of things you probably can't think of
most of the old dudes that do that
actually
um
their bodies don't look don't look that
bad most of the age shows in the face of
the head and and depending on how lean
he is
but in leaner leaner kind of older guys
if you didn't see the head you wouldn't
know how old that dude was
to just cut his head off and everything
will be fine yeah
that's how that goes
uh Ben says my grandma in her 90s and
mother in her 70s we're always talking
about how suspicious they were of any
males and Grandma's retirement home
becoming too friendly because they're
after someone to look after them
that's what the old ladies in the group
said
what does that mean meaning that I guess
like old guys are trying to get laid
well no I don't think it's that I think
that a lot of them are probably widowed
so they want like another like somebody
that's like their wife that's gonna like
take care of them like in their old age
those are dudes that didn't have any
skills to begin with you probably
couldn't cook or either
yeah see that's one thing about about
Tom he can cook oh yeah he can do all
his own [__] yeah you know what I mean
except shave his back guys my bag
okay Jen comes home from work and I'll
have [__] food cooked [__] strong
bully I have everything you know like a
damn housewife it's ridiculous he's
already got it on my desk ready for when
I come home yeah is that awesome yeah I
know I love it anytime I don't get that
homemade [__] ricotta cheese and
everything
I know you like to cook though yeah I
like it yeah
so it's not like I never thought I never
thought of you that way as like a kind
of I'm just kind of like well
I'm the kind of I'm the kind of
[__] I'm just trying to make it
easier for you that's what I that's what
I mean it's just like whoever is free at
the moment yeah like and has to do the
[__] that we're both gonna then who then
they'll do it you know what I mean like
I don't like I said and I came home from
work yesterday and you were like um I
need you to shave my back yeah and I was
like okay
eyes up but he you shaved my head also
because he had to shave my head also
because I had to dye my hair
but you know what I mean
um Camp guy said uh I can still chub up
every day at 61. so yeah I'm not um go
on test it'll get even better yeah I'm
not concerned about like age so much
anymore especially since I'm kind of
getting up there myself but
and especially because nowadays it's
really not the same as it used to be it
depends on a person I mean it depends on
the person like I have seen some people
that were younger than me that um yeah
but it's and it some you I think
genetics is partially is a factor I
think the biggest factor is Diet
lifestyle
if you live a sedentary lifestyle and
you've gained a bunch of weight
it's hard to reverse the damage of
having a lot of weight on you
um it can be done
but you'll never really fully recover
not without surgery
because you have a lot of loose skin
especially if you're young you might be
able to absorb a lot of it but when
you're older that's what yeah that's
kind of what they don't tell you why
don't you use a lot of weed if you're
older yeah you lose a lot of weight
you're older which is good you should
but it's like you know it might not you
might not look as awesome as you right
but um if you're smart all the
technology all the biotechnologies out
there you want to use hormone
replacement
and more I I have therapeutic cycles of
steroids [__] lifting weights cardio
good diet
don't abuse your body with alcohol and
drugs too much although look your body's
[__] amazing you can get drunk you
can get high as long as you don't overdo
it you can shake it back I mean
everything in moderation everything in
moderation like we drink a lot sometimes
but we don't drink every day right it's
not like we're not I don't I wouldn't
call this alcoholics or anything
I do like a drinker before but not every
day though we're pretty Physically
Active she works out I work out
got a gym right over there yeah right in
the Next Room by The Next Room matter of
fact
uh Zach says why we need to get you Jim
what's that we need to get you those
damn elastic rubber bands to work your
legs
yeah I used to have something yeah so
you could do the outside of your thighs
and [__] yeah I know what you're talking
about yeah like I said I used to have
some of those we need some of those and
you do some resistance too
Zach says my last couple relationships
have been open so cheating isn't exactly
a problem now is it I feel like gay
dudes have a lot easier time with it
that seems very common it's all just
dudes that's what I mean I think yeah I
think maybe that's why because it's all
different and they're like yeah we know
how dudes yeah we all dudes and [__]
and and they all into each other you
know yeah another one yeah okay fine
well it's nothing is you know Jen
uh you know I wouldn't say Jess full-on
by but Jen likes certain girls
um we fooled around a little bit and so
it's not quite the same you know what I
mean frigid as it would be like gay
dudes you know but um
it's not to say that me and Jen get a
little girlfriend it's not the same as a
full-on relationship with somebody else
all the time because they usually they
have their own lives then they go back
to their husbands and it's just we don't
really take it that seriously there are
friends of ours though they're not just
like random people yeah we're not real
big on we're not [__] yeah we're not
[__] we gotta know you we gotta like
you you know what I mean yeah I I have
to have hung out with you for a lot and
like like you as a person before
anything like that's gonna happen and
they tend to be real cuties
to hear pretty much
because like I said I have a hard time
just like
yeah I can't you don't want to do random
people that's what I mean I can't really
get into like doing random places like I
have done that but it's just like I
don't it's not really yeah those are
dudes though that's what I yeah not not
random chicks yeah just like random
dudes but it's that parents are kind of
higher for women
yeah well we have a lot more to lose
yeah so it's not as easy no I'm just
saying if you're gonna hook up with some
girl you're gonna [__] women women's
gonna hook up with a girl or the
standards are gonna be higher for that
girl yeah than a guy because there's got
to be a reason why
and [__] update Jen's main one that
she wanted me to [__] get for us
[__] um
I'm just gonna call her Saint Mary
turns out she got a boyfriend she moved
with she moved away the [__] dealt to
Daytona but she'll she'll be back around
she'll back around she's gonna be coming
to momentum next Friday next Friday I
thought it was this Friday but yeah next
Friday yeah she's cute though she's cute
I didn't know that she was uh Mexican or
half Mexican
yeah we did it we found it on Facebook
found her on Facebook he's like
he's trying to like every time like I'm
kind of like hey that girl's cute or
something like that he always like goes
behind my back and like stress like yeah
yeah and then he tries to like hook it
up that's trying to hook it up well he
knows I'm not gonna do it because I'm
like kind of shy yeah
and here's the thing is the [__]
I'm not trying to get anybody laid or
anything that's not exactly what it was
the [__] could have been platonic Jen
just needs some friend she could geek
out with you know everybody's [__]
hang out with he's trying to find me
like some some nerdy horror girl yeah
he's like a nerdy horror girl she got me
Jen likes nerds and somebody to hang out
with yeah I'm into her buddy I mean I'm
into boy nerds too but I like girl nerds
yeah
I wanna yeah I want like another horror
nerd like yeah or another like MST nerd
right so she found out what we what I
was doing well I mean we weren't real
settling
she was funny but I am straight we were
it was that bad yeah we used to see her
all the time and I was like she is so
cute look at her yeah yeah we liked her
yeah she's super cute and she's super
funny yeah she's just super funny and I
was like that girl is just adorable and
so Tom's like I'm gonna get her I'm
gonna get it for you
so he's like trying to and I was just
like oh God I don't want to be involved
I don't want to know what's going to
happen was there what happened was is
that she was kind of sweet on me but she
didn't know I had a girlfriend
she saw you and she got scared
she felt like she she felt like she was
although I told you I was like I'm not
scary I don't know what she's she
thought she thought that she was
stepping on your territory so
so I was like no it's okay come come
meet Jan and [__]
hold up and evidently some of our
friends said no no you can be Jen they
they get girlfriends and she's like oh
I'm not into that she [__] oh so some
of our others
[__] kind of like portrayed it in a
certain way that it is it's not entirely
accurate apparently we haven't really
done it that many times a couple times
just a couple of times yeah it's not
like we're all constantly growl
everybody's like in [__] Dangerous
Liaisons or something like that we're
not like that no we're just bring the
people it's almost like it's because it
comes it kind of comes across like we're
like some predatory [__] like in the
Hunger like we're going around like
looking for somebody that's not what it
is drain their blood or something it's
like yeah we don't do that we've only
done it like once or twice it's not
really that so she's like so our friends
got a hold of her and scared her okay
accidentally not on purpose well yeah
okay yeah they were just I don't know
yeah yeah oh it's fine it's fine you
know it's fine those [__] are always
doing it they always do that
and then that scared her even so yeah
you know
we're not that bad yeah oh my God but
then she came over later with her with
the little guy that she was seeing at
the time remember that goofy little
[__] that he was funny I thought
he was funny actually guy kept throwing
himself on the floor and doing the
[__] backflips and [__] oh yeah yeah
she's not with that dude though she
[__] gotta got a handsome guy vampire
looking dude
yeah I've never seen him but I've seen a
picture of him
yeah she was like I need a new place to
live I am very low income
I said you are me too babe yeah me too
low haircut
that's just [__] funny Tom is always
trying he he was also trying to hook me
up with the nerdy girl that works at the
Publix Bakery yeah yeah who is like wait
she's like young enough to her daughter
dude yeah that's okay
Haley was like our daughter oh
yeah before she died that's yeah yeah
that's a girl that's terrible yeah yeah
she passed away
but cancer she was very young yeah
boy man that's sad I know yeah you just
brought the whole [__] show down
thanks a lot [__] [__] it up yeah
but uh no that was just no I saw that
one I saw that one in the parking lot I
go there she is for you Jim was like
yeah every time like yeah every time
like he sees like a little wispy nerdy
girl yeah with glasses there's your
girlfriend there she is and I'm just
like yeah all right
she walks by and I just and I said how
are you doing and she goes how are you
doing and Jenny's
and I was like oh man I see her every
now and then you see when you go in
there and you see her yeah you didn't
talk to her not really I mean I went to
the Publix the other day and she was
behind did she recognize you I don't
think so okay
because she because you're not dressed
up you come back to work when you go
there yes so I'm not like as fancy as I
would be normally
on the weekend kind of a little bit goth
yeah
although you never can't tell with the
younger ones you know like you don't
really you don't really well yeah but
you don't really know what they're into
you know what I mean like back in the
old days if you saw somebody that was
into that like the you'd know they'd be
like into most of the same [__] as you
but now it is it's she's not that young
she's probably 26.
that's young that's still young enough
to be my kid that's almost 30.
almost that's an adult
I know it's in it that was out of the
service by that time I know it's an
adult I'm just saying she's young enough
to be my daughter it might be a little
weird I don't know I don't really think
of it as that weird but
I don't know yeah so many people we know
of all these different ages it doesn't
think I'm really bad that's true I guess
I don't really think about it all that
much you're not remembering who had all
these the club that we know that are
about that age well when you talk to
them you don't really get the sense that
they're half your age you know what I
mean because they talk about the same
[__] that you like and they're not
treating you as an old person right yeah
and it's kind of the same thing like it
kind of work works both ways like
everyone's just kind of on the same page
so it doesn't really which is kind of
nice actually you know
um all kinds of sexual talk going on in
there
Michael says you ain't no moderate
drinkers huh yeah
average I would say we drink more than
average okay I do I will admit that uh
no they're well for an American yeah
it's not as far as like a European or a
British person or [__] Irish person
they now when I lived in the UK
girlfriend she was [__] when I lived
in the UK I was flabbergasted Yeah by
how much they drank yeah
yeah but um and it was just like a cat
which is fine it was just like a casual
thing it's like every day man they would
just drink a drink and it's just kind of
like like I said we drink a lot when we
go out we drink a lot when we do the
show but it's like when we're not doing
the show or we're not going out we don't
yeah usually
you know so it's not like we're just
another [__] we gotta do man that's what
I mean it's like usually like well you
know I work every day like for many many
hours and then on the weekends we're
usually doing
other stuff where you usually do it
working on other I'm usually doing
videos we're doing stuff for streaming
or like videos for that or something
like that so we can't be too [__] up
you know
but
um but as far as the girlfriends thing
go [__] these little nerds that I'm
trying to dig up for did it doesn't have
to be a [__] sexual thing I'm just
looking for some a buddy that Jenna
could hang out with and have friends she
needs a girlfriend a female friend so I
can nerd out so she can nerd out so he
doesn't have to listen to me nerd out
about her because I hang out with dudes
I can hang out with other bikers on [__]
bike night and go down to [__] you
know what I mean so you haven't been a
bike in a while now yeah but it's
because the times and what's been going
on well last Tuesday was Fourth of July
so yeah
so you know what I mean
Jed needs a buddy even though she's got
a lot of them it's just that they're
working
yeah it's hard for me like
and we live in Eustis and we live kind
of far away from them and it's just like
so I can't really yeah like every now
and then like some of us will like kind
of get like go to downtown Sanford or
something like that but we haven't done
that in a really long time
and honestly to I don't know to be
honest whenever I'm gonna like nerd out
about horror with somebody it's usually
a dude which is yeah
which is bad in this day and age because
I know there's a lot of chicks who like
horror too but it's like I don't meet a
lot of them
or at least a lot of them that are like
as nerdy about our design you know you
know
so it's like oh they got her they got
they got a show well that's what I mean
yeah they have their own [__] [__]
going on you know who nerds out with
horror with horror movies about is
Dimitri yeah Dimitri he nerds out on
horror I didn't know that you know he
watched it that much oh [__] he loves
that [__] Wendy's always asking me for
like recommendations and stuff okay and
then and he's seen like some weird like
more obscure [__] than I've seen so we
always kind of like trade like [__]
uh you know recommendations Dimitri's
our club buddy he's he's uh he's the DJ
moment yeah and his wife I think we've
shown pictures of her you know and their
daughter that that family there is a
[__] trip man
that daughter of theirs
was a cute little like 12 year old one
day and then the next day she's [__]
18 and Pregnant and [__] running off
of some dude and
and it happened it seemed like it
happened overnight didn't it
yeah I mean yeah yeah
but I mean I remember them his name is
Jen too yeah she's she uh the lead
singer of a band called [__] uh 13th
Angel 13th Angel long black hair Pretty
Woman
and um
it's funny the daughter looks like a
perfect combination of both of them yeah
she's got Dimitri's nose
yeah and the rest of her looks like Jed
looks like Jen with Dimitri's nose yeah
Dimitri's stuck in Greek yeah because
Greek America
dude for [__] a long time now
probably what 13 years now
10 years at least huh yeah a long time
it's been at least a decade yeah did
Club business with him
well like I said Memento is still going
yeah he's always wanting me to [__] a
cook man he wants to come over and
[__] eat [__] Indian chickpeas and
[__] ever since then yeah ever since
they came to the house and you made
butter chicken that time he's just he
still hasn't stop talking about butter
chicken we're gonna make butter chicken
again
your butter chicken is out of this world
well I got three different ones I make I
know but I mean they're all good
uh Ben said if you lived in the UK you
would drink you would drink that much
too yeah I mean yeah it's probably not
as active probably not as much to do
there actually probably like being in
Boston because I lived in Boston which
is very much kind of like London I've
heard
maybe the way London used to be
it looks like Eggman
there's not a lot to do there except
Drake [__] pubs everywhere
drinking and clubbing and working that's
it
well that's kind of what everybody does
they go to the pub you know what I mean
there's no outdoor activities you know
you can't ride motorcycles
a lot of people do outdoor [__] like
they'll go like play soccer and [__]
like that because there's a lot of you
know Sports grounds and stuff
and actually when I lived over there
they um I would go to the sports center
and swim and there was like a lot of
people there's women America in general
the North American continent and the
life inside the there's depends on what
state you're into and the regions it's
all different because it's like a bunch
of it's basically like the EU it's a
bunch of different countries in general
North America has more in common
probably with Australia than it does
England
probably closer to Australians
yeah I always kind of thought yeah
I mean it's hard to say because there's
so many different I mean the US is so
big and it hasn't
different regions and ship I like the
desert region
because everyone's kids love it
but but I like the [__] Florida
Florida's like the jungle region this is
subtropical or Diego swamp actually
swamp Mississippi was kind of like that
too it's kind of like they may call him
Delta in a certain way [__]
coniferous forest [__] subtropical
hot [__] Hammond
Louisiana same thing there's more
Dagobah
I'm not into it man I don't like I don't
like this constant swamp Ash you know
what I mean Northeast is just kind of
cold and dry see I prefer that
I'm wearing a cold dry Rainey or or
rainy I like cold just
not as much Freedom it's too much
population density
I'd rather I kind of would probably like
the [__] Midwest of Michigan was okay
um kind of depressing winter time it's
kind of like American version of Siberia
um
some of that stuff like Wyoming has big
plain states that might those might be
pretty nice there's probably not a lot
to do out there but
I didn't like cutting I like certain
elements of old California I wouldn't
like it now
but I liked California as a kid
it's too built up now too many problems
um
one thing good about California though
is they had beautiful mountains Sierra
Nevada mountains were great Yosemite
Yellowstone Park man this is nice
Camp guy said if I drink a lot I have to
pee about every 45 minutes yeah same
same with me man [__] I'm not into
I'm not quite as bad but it's like if if
we if we drink before we go to sleep
then I'll wake up two or three times
yeah like to go to the bathroom in the
middle of the night and Camp guy said um
I Heard it I heard a dude at an AAA
meeting say you used to piss the bed
because he was too drunk to get up yeah
I mean I've heard of that happen I've
actually I've personally I've never had
that happen but um I have heard of other
people had that happen
and I think we've told the story in the
show before
but one night had we was it
I can't remember where we went I would
do I think we were at mannequins or
Barbarella like um you know momentumori
and we came home and we went to sleep
and then I woke up at
three four in the morning something like
that
and Tom was standing like at the end of
our bed as like this it's one of those
benches that you can like lift it you
can push it in you know what I mean
so he was just standing there and like I
said it was very Paranormal Activity
because like I woke up it's like the
middle of the night and I'm waking up
and he's just like standing there like
still and I was like oh this is [__]
creepy this is just like Paranormal
Activity and I was like
um what you doing
and he said pissing
and I was like are you being on the
floor and he's like and if I guess he
was asleep but he was like so drunk that
he was like sleeping that he thought he
was in the bathroom he hadn't actually
peed on the floor or anything like that
but he didn't actually know where he was
he's like oh [__] and then like he kind
of went to the bathroom but it's just
kind of like
I could see that happening I mean I've
been
that I've been drunk enough where that
could have happened but I said luckily
that's never happened to me
but I've been drunk enough where it
probably could have happened
Michael says um
oh I was telling the story about how I
woke up in the middle of the night that
time and saw you like standing there
thinking European yeah I thought I was
pissing
because I was like because I said well
well if I was creeped out because I said
it was just like Paranormal Activity I
don't know if you saw that movie but
it's just like you were just standing
there still and it was creeping me out
yeah Michael says why is Tom always
repping Canon why what you're sure oh
dude I made this shirt [__]
Jen actually did all the graphics I made
the [__] um
the the screen for it and I shoot it
every now and then I'll get a shirt and
I'll turn it into a [__] Cannon shirt
this is the [__] greatest [__]
B-movie company of all time
Superman [__] Superman 4. oh the
Chuck Norris [__] it yeah hell yeah
Cannon Canon films being Canon films
yeah
that's kind of what I associate it with
Tammy said I'm already looking forward
to Winter this heat is killing me yeah
same
I know I was thinking about today I'm
like only a few months until it's Autumn
I mean it'll still be hot here but at
least it won't be summer anymore Camp
guy said alcohol affects different
people in different ways I know a lady
that started drinking and she was dead
within two years holy [__]
Camp guy says I think I've heard Tom
talk about different effects on
different people what exactly are you
talking about alcohol alcohol yeah yeah
yeah I mean it's just like everything
else yeah everything affects people
differently honestly I didn't even
really and I think I mentioned this
before I didn't really even start
drinking
until I was in my 30s probably yeah like
I would drink every now and then like
when I was a teenager in my 20s or
something but it wasn't really something
I did all that much
but it wasn't really until I was like
maybe in my 30s and I started clubbing
and then I started
you know regularly and I started
drinking more but
so I don't know I figure I'm probably
okay because I didn't grow up with it my
parents didn't really drink they didn't
really care that much about it so it
wasn't really in the house or anything
like that
is there is Pookie biting you she's
trying to
you need that much attention
play Ben says I once was so drunk I
slipped in the kitchen and fell into the
rubbish bin and couldn't get out
[Laughter]
I don't mean to laugh but it's like I'm
trying to what's the most [__] up [__]
I did when I was watching uh most [__]
up thing you ever did when you were
drunk is uh
smack man we were driving home you
smacking on top of the [__] head well
I remember that called me all kinds of
[__]
uh and then started throwing up and you
wouldn't roll the window down in time
and I'm driving and you threw up outside
the window all down the side of the car
and in the inside of the car and the
next day I had to [__] blast it all
out hose
that was the most busted and I remember
and I remember being messed up because
I've been drinking I think vodka and
cranberry all night and when I came out
and saw the throw up on the side of the
car I started I thought I was throwing
up blood now it was all red and I was
like oh yeah
I remember that yeah yeah that was it
was funny it was pretty funny
I don't remember what you did but you
did something oh you accused me of
something
well you probably did some [__] up you
probably said some [__] up [__] you're
always saying it doesn't matter it was
one of those you don't love me because
you're always you're always saying
[__] up [__] you're always saying that
[__] up [__]
no I was well I never fell in a rubbish
bin though
now okay now one time this was before me
and you got together
but I think I did
um I was out with this dude that I was
dating and we got kind of drunk and we
were having sex on the hood of a car in
front of someone's house like just
parked on the side of the road so we did
that but
yeah they're talking about Charles
Bronson and can't yeah well the sex on
the hood yeah
I did that [__] in high school well
that's what I'm saying but I was just
like that's that was something that just
came to mind yeah
hopefully the neighbors didn't look out
the window but you know no let him see
man
Tammy said we all know you deserved it
Tom
no
[Laughter]
you probably did I don't I don't
remember what it was but more drugs she
got the more the
more sensitive she gets
and that was a different time too
that's true that was another time I
don't think he quite had the same
understandings about things back in
those days
it was a long time ago
yeah
we have kind of like gotten to it kind
of chilled out we've kind of chilled out
as we've gotten older I guess
laughs
Zach says most drunk I've ever been was
the first time I had honey flavored Jack
Daniels oh that [__] which holy [__]
that's the grossest [__] I've ever seen
no I actually I actually like you have
to drink that on the Rocks you can't mix
that
yeah and it's I can see if you drink too
much of it then it'd probably be like
overwhelming because it is kind of sweet
um I had that Jim Beam apple green I
like that too yeah I wish it was good it
wasn't a Jim Beamer was a jacket yeah
well Jack Daniels makes an apple too
which is also good they taste kind of
similar okay but the one the one that we
had was Jimmy I think it was Jim B Jim
Beam Apple yeah
she was really good
it's a sipping whiskey you know just put
it over ice yeah it's not really one
although I will admit
the honey one somebody gave me a big
bottle my friend Liz
gave me a big bottle of Honey Jack
Daniels for Christmas one year and I had
it in my car
and we went to a concert at the House of
Blues at Downtown Disney
and we had to wait in line for a really
long time so we stopped at 7-Eleven and
got a big gulp and poured a a
substantial dollop of of the Honey Jack
Daniels in there so we wouldn't have to
buy So Many Drinks when we went inside
because they were expensive and we just
sat out there and like [__] drank
from this big gulp that also had like a
whole lot of whiskey in it I think uh
Jack Daniels also had that cinnamon
flavor didn't it was that Jim Beam I
mean yeah I think they both do I think
it was called fire or something I don't
really like the cinnamon ones I like
like I said they give me heartburning I
liked it
but I think it was Jim Beam Apple I was
drinking Jim Beam apple and Coca-Cola if
you mix them together
tastes exactly like a Brazilian soft
drink called guarana
[__] it tastes just like it it's
beautiful
to me like what Squadron I had some of
these energy drinks have it people go
people mispronounced as garenara no it's
not [__] that's just great
you can get that actually guadala it's
my Publix yeah they sell it just in the
right it's in the ethnic foods
usually it comes in a green can
yeah and it's it's kind of like the
Brazilian version of root beer but their
version of root beer doesn't taste
anything like ours it doesn't taste like
sassafras it kind of tastes like Sprite
with a slight hint of cherry Maybe
kinda
and honey that's just [__] delicious
move to Brazil and [__] drank that
[__] of the man [__] a South American
Central America have [__] flavors
that North America could never imagine
they got fruit down there they're
[__] we don't have they got weird ass
fruit down there good fruit it doesn't
it doesn't make it this far north God
damn
good drag racing in the dam well it is
Friday night yeah
very last both Central and South America
have wonderful food I [__] love it
and some of it's in the in the cookbook
that that I made
that Jen made that is all the [__] I
came out with
thuggins so if you guys want to know how
to make Brazilian food I got it written
down in there yeah we got some Brazilian
food yeah
we still got to go to that Brazilian
steakhouse yeah you want to get ready to
spend 100 a person well it's your high
school Josh Korea Brazilian barbecue
we'll have to do that for like a special
occasion I guess
you got to go there very hungry
see that's the problem it's just kind of
like all you can eat I can't really eat
that much at one time yeah it's gonna be
beef and pork and chicken and [__]
man this shit's delicious you're gonna
love it so that's kind of what happens
whenever we get a koi one or Ichiban or
whatever it's just kind of like I want
to eat all the things but I can't eat
all the things
like I have a plate and then like I
believe it
okay maybe believing it oh reconnection
successful I'll believe it when I say
there it is okay it's in the back it's
back says it's back we were talking
about koi won okay
so a couple weeks back we're at koiwan
we got there we like to get there like
not too long after they open because
like all the food's fresh you would
presume yeah so we get there like 11 11
30. now this one dude
was like at a table like over there like
candy cornered from us and he was there
before we got there he was one dude just
by himself
now when we got there and I don't know
how long he'd been there prior to us
getting there so he could have been
eating a lot more of this
but he was there and he had a plate with
a humongous
pile of boiled shrimp on it like
humongous
and he just sat there and like very
systematically like ate all of that and
I was like wow look at that and so then
I wasn't like watching him watching him
I was just like I could kind of see him
out of the corner of my eye and then
like so he eats all that and then he
goes and then he comes back and he has
this big huge plate of I think it was um
crawfish a big plate of crawfish and he
sits there and systematically like he's
this isn't a fat dude it was like a tall
like it's corn sort of skinny dude like
he wasn't skinny skinny but he wasn't
fat either
so he eats this whole [__] thing of
of uh crawfish
then he goes back and then he goes and
gets like a bunch of crab legs or like
that they have like the cold blue crabs
yeah if deep fried blue crab right so he
then how to eat those whole platter full
of those and he sat there and
systematically ate all of those he just
kept yeah look dude I ate like two
plates and then I was like yeah I'm kind
of full yeah well he just kept going
back and came and he might have been
eating before we got him like where the
[__] is he putting it all well look six
pounds of crawfish six pounds of
crawfish might only yield a [__]
quarter pound of meat it's mostly shell
because I saw him come back with like
plates of other food and it was like a
pile
you know yeah like when I go to those
places it's like I try to economize
because I know I can't eat that much so
I'm just kind of like well I want I want
some of this and I want some of this so
I just get like a little bit of each
thing so I can have a little bit I'm
gonna talk about Boone's Farm Strawberry
Wine I don't know why I brought that up
but I got stories about that grew up as
a kid in California
my mom and all her friends used to take
Boon's Farm Strawberry Wine and mix it
with seven up yeah because that was hard
like they didn't have wine cooler
coolers and that's the way the wine cool
that's where the wine cooler came from
came from Californian girls mixing the
mixing those about 50 50.
and as a little kid
they were people weren't real uptight
about little kids drinking
yeah they just kind of thought as funny
yeah yeah it is kind of fun they drink
that and I said let me have some of that
and you're out your ah or your mom would
say yeah here have some it's just a wine
cooler you know what I mean and it was
you drink it yeah I mean like you were
good like my family weren't big drinkers
but yeah if somebody had beers or
something like that yeah give us a beer
that's hilarious like that in Europe I
think even today it was like that in
Brazil yeah they don't care
when it's not gonna kill one time one
time this is my start what time me and
my two neighbor kids Jimmy and Mike
Jimmy was my age we were probably about
seven me and Jimmy Mike was probably
about 10.
might have been a little bit younger
it might have been more like six he
might have Mike might have been more
like eight uh sometimes it's hard to
know I think it was probably around 76
which it may be seven yeah that's
probably about seven
I'd already had a y cooler I knew it
came out of that Dam
balloon's Farm jug and Jimmy and micro
over at my house and they saw that jug
because their mom drank wine coolers too
look wine and I said yeah let's drink
some
so it's a big old [__] glass jug it
had a [__] circle on it like a you
know you put your finger through it like
a [__] yeah it's got a little handle
yeah like a little [__] wine or not
what it called like yeah like one of
those old cartoons yeah
so we're [__] picking a jug up we're
helping each other lift it
because it was big it's like that's
adorable like thinking about like little
kids being like I'll help you so we
started drinking it in a house you know
I mean for here you get them you know
we ended up in the [__] front yard
on the [__]
sidewalk
drinking [__] Boons Farm wine waving
at the cars if the car is going by this
is on our block you know it was on
Jackson Street down in Carson
[Laughter]
and I remember [__] adults like dudes
they were probably teenage guys really
you know [__] seeing us out there
[__] drinking that [__] like look at
this Hawking the horn and waving again
yeah you get it you get it that's
hilarious we were [__] blasted I mean
honestly I'd probably do this I'm like
oh my God drunk six year olds that's
hysterical yeah well word got out
bird got out and [__] um Jimmy and
Mike's mom her name was Yvonne she came
running down the street [__] she took
the bottle from us
I went back to the house and just [__]
fell asleep never heard anything about
it my mom knew about it though she's
just laughing they were out there drunk
because you know in the 70s you know if
I can didn't have helicopter parents and
[__] they just let you [__] they'd
let you run wild you were like feral
children
it was just part of growing up it was
funny
getting into the booth I mean like it is
pretty funny yeah so I get into the news
maybe it's not funny
it didn't hurt us like I said if I saw
some six-year-olds like sitting on a
yeah in the lawn like chugging [__]
boots yeah we were helping each other
[__] because I could just stop and
take a picture of that [__] like I'm
like oh my God that's hysterical we were
helping each other tip The Jug see
that's the best part yeah because it was
like because it was too heavy it was too
heavy so you have to have the other
little kid like help yeah yeah you're
like get underneath it and [__] oh my
God that's so funny
and that's why Tom's the way he is
this bike Tammy said uh talking about
the dude that I was talking about at koi
won he went to the Tom Ross School of
how to eat at a buffet see that's what I
was thinking because he seemed very
systematic and like the way he was going
about stuff which Tom also is kind of
like that too I got a pattern well I
mean you kind of have to it's weird
because when you go to I mean we don't
go to them all the time but it's like
you know we go to like a lot of Asian
buffets and you do kind of have to like
strategize a little bit I found because
what I had been doing at koiwan was I
would was doing what you were doing
where I would get like
cold stuff first like I would get like
you know the boiled shrimp and like some
mussels and stuff like that but I found
that it was actually better on my
stomach
if I got a small plate of like a
selection of like hot things first like
I'd get like a little bit of pepper
steak a little bit of chicken and
broccoli or whatever and then like the
second plate I would get like all the
cold stuff you know like shrimp and crab
or whatever like cold crab salad or
whatever so I would get that kind of
stuff it seemed to like work out better
because I don't know
I I feel like if I ate shrimp first like
I would eat more in the end then I'd
like regret it later like I would start
feeling really sick because really I can
only eat about two plates and then and
like Tom will not only eat like three or
four plates but then he'll like go and
get ice cream yeah [__] time on top of
it yeah shit's on ice cream although
last time I didn't get any ice cream but
I did notice that they had like some
almond cookies that were like shortbread
yeah I did get one of those and those
were like really good but mostly like
for dessert I just had fruit I just had
like some melon and stuff well it's 10
30. we got a [__] good and shut this
down probably yeah I gotta clean up in
the kitchen downstairs too oh you do
[__] yeah gotta put the food away oh
okay you want some more um uh you got
another half of that yeah it's gonna be
cold though that's okay okay it's good
like that all right all right so we're
gonna wrap it up getting a little bit
late and I've been up since probably
like 3 30. like I woke up at like three
o'clock in the morning because I had to
pee and then I couldn't go back to sleep
and then I had to get up at five so so
I've been up since like three o'clock
this morning like this morning like
yesterday morning so yeah I'm a little
bit tired so hopefully you guys have a
good rest of your Friday evening and
hopefully you guys have a good day
tomorrow and we'll be back on Sunday I'm
not entirely sure what movie we'll be
talking about it will either be Megan
which we watched or Dreamscape from the
80s which we also watched or if we
decide to watch Renfield which I think
is on peacock then it might be that
movie so it could be like any one of
those three I'm not actually sure which
one we're doing yet but it'll be one of
those three probably so hopefully you
guys can come by Sunday and watch the
movie review thank everybody for
dropping by this evening and hanging out
with us and we will see you guys again
on Sunday evening
good night